Welcome to our second drink of frame Toby. Ah, frame Toby. Michael is horrified because Toby is back at Dunder Mifflin, so he's going to try to get rid of him, obviously, by framing him with drugs that he got from Leo and Gino. Ah, well, we have great behind-the-scenes details in this episode from our producers Randy Cordray and James Carey and writers Jen Salata and Paul Lieberstein.
欢迎来到我们的第二杯《Framed Toby》。啊，《Framed Toby》。迈克尔感到非常震惊，因为托比回到了邓德·米夫林，所以他显然打算通过栽赃托比持有从里奥和吉诺那里弄来的毒品来除掉他。啊，好吧，在本集中，我们的制片人兰迪·科德雷和詹姆斯·凯里，以及编剧简·萨拉塔和保罗·利伯斯坦为我们提供了精彩的幕后细节。
So many good nuggets. And thanks to everyone who wrote in to share their thoughts about this episode. Just a reminder, y'all, we have all of Season 5's episodes in a folder on our website, OfficeLadies.com. So go in there and write us your thoughts on the upcoming episodes because we love hearing from you. And we are going to kick off today's second drink with a theme that several people connected with. And Jenna, you and I discussed some of this in our is Toby the Scranton Strangler debate episode that we did? Yes.
太多的干货了。感谢每一位写信分享对本集看法的朋友。提醒大家一下，我们在网站 OfficeLadies.com 的文件夹里整理了第五季的所有剧集。所以请去那里写下你们对接下来剧集的想法，因为我们很喜欢听你们的反馈。今天，我们将以一个许多人都产生共鸣的主题开启我们的第二杯。珍娜，你和我曾在我们讨论“托比是斯克兰顿勒杀手吗”的那一集里探讨过这个问题，对吧？是的。
Well, listen to this. Julia G from Littleton, Colorado says, my question is, do you think the reason Michael hates Toby so much is that deep down, he knows that Toby has it in him to become the Scranton Strangler? I mean...
好吧，听听这个。来自科罗拉多州利特尔顿的朱莉娅·G 说，我的问题是，你认为迈克尔如此讨厌托比的原因，是否是因为他内心深处知道托比有成为斯克兰顿勒杀手的潜质？我是说……
Yes, Julia, yes. No, Julia. I don't think you know where I stand on it. This is our whole debate episode. Even if Toby was the Scranton Strangler, Michael would miss all the signs. Well, listen, Now, we've already debated this in a whole episode.
是的，朱莉娅，是的。不，朱莉娅。我不认为你知道我的立场。这是我们整个辩论的主题。即使托比真的是斯克兰顿勒杀手，迈克尔也会错过所有的迹象。好吧，听着，我们已经在整整一集里辩论过这个问题了。
Well, I'm not going to get into it here. If Toby is this Grant Strangler, I'm just saying if he was, Michael wouldn't clock it. I don't think Michael's anger at Toby has anything to do with this strangler business. Sometimes Michael has spidey sense about people, so I don't know. Okay. Well, maybe. Maybe. Well, we also got a letter from Hannah B from Ontario who said,
好吧，我不想在这里深入讨论。如果托比是斯克兰顿勒杀手，我只是说如果他是，迈克尔也不会察觉到。我不认为迈克尔对托比的愤怒与这个勒杀手的事情有任何关系。有时迈克尔对人有种“蜘蛛感应”，所以我不知道。好吧，也许吧。也许。好吧，我们还收到了一封来自安大略省汉娜·B 的信，她说，
do we think Toby's defensive reaction to having his things searched by? the cops is evidence toward him being the strangler. But Hannah also wanted to acknowledge Creed. Hannah points out that Creed is clearly guilty of having narcotics in the office. And this is maybe evidence confirming his need for two chairs to access his sealing grow operation, which I thought was very funny. Mm-hmm. I have to say, though, Hannah also pointed out that Toby is also normally passive and non-confrontational, and she was surprised when he got defensive, especially if he didn't have anything to hide. I'm just saying. What is happening right now? Are we reopening this debate? We are not, but we did get mail that made me laugh about it. But we also got a fan mail flurry, lady.
我们是否认为托比对警察搜查他的东西所表现出的防御性反应，是他就是勒杀手的证据？但汉娜也想提一下克里德。汉娜指出，克里德显然在办公室里藏有毒品。这或许能证实他需要两把椅子来进入他的天花板种植基地，我觉得这非常有趣。嗯哼。不过我得说，汉娜也指出托比通常是被动且不爱对抗的，当他表现出防御性时，她感到很惊讶，尤其是如果他没什么可隐瞒的话。我只是随口一说。现在发生了什么？我们是在重新开启这场辩论吗？我们没有，但我们收到的邮件确实让我笑了。不过，女士，我们还收到了一阵粉丝来信。
Yes, we sure did. We got a fan mail flurry from Damon H. Layton R from California, Miranda D from Australia, Joyce S from Oklahoma, who all wrote in to say that their favorite scene from this episode is when Michael sees Toby is back and screams no. And Yasmin Y in Dallas, Texas said, did you know that there is a YouTube compilation video which has Michael's no, no, in clips in multiple languages? I did not know that. Yasmin says, it's hilarious. Look it up if you haven't seen it. Since neither of us had, lady, I pulled the clip, but there's a lot of people yell and know at you in different languages. So let's hear three of them. Hi, my God! No, God! Please no! No! No! No!
是的，确实如此。我们收到了一阵来自加利福尼亚州的达蒙·H、莱顿·R，澳大利亚的米兰达·D，俄克拉荷马州的乔伊斯·S 的粉丝来信，他们都写信说，他们在本集中最喜欢的场景是迈克尔看到托比回来时尖叫“不”。达拉斯的雅斯敏·Y 说，你知道 YouTube 上有一个汇编视频，里面有迈克尔用多种语言说“不，不”的片段吗？我不知道。雅斯敏说，这太搞笑了。如果你还没看过，去搜一下。既然我们俩都没看过，女士，我把那个片段找出来了，但有很多人用不同语言对你大喊“不”。所以让我们听听其中的三个。天哪！不，上帝！求你了，不！不！不！不！
No! No! Hi, Michael! No! No! No! God! Bitter! Nine! Nine! Nine! Nine! No! Ciao, my son. No, oh, God. No, dear, to pray go. No. No. No.
不！不！嗨，迈克尔！不！不！不！上帝！Bitter！Nine！Nine！Nine！Nine！不！Ciao，我的儿子。不，哦，上帝。不，亲爱的，去祈祷吧。不。不。不。
No. No. No, God. No, God. No, God, I'm sorry. No. No. It's literally funny in every language.
不。不。不，上帝。不，上帝。不，上帝，我很抱歉。不。不。它在每种语言里都真的很好笑。
It literally is. You know what it is? I think some of it is the timing and the emphasis, which is all Steve Carell. Yeah. He laid. the template for that beat and they follow along perfectly. Yes.
确实如此。你知道这是为什么吗？我想部分原因是节奏和强调，这全靠史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。是的。他为那个节拍奠定了模板，而他们完美地跟上了。是的。
Brilliant. But it is funny. It is funny in multiple languages. Oh, another storyline people really enjoyed was about the dirty microwave in the kitchen and how no one wanted to clean it or take responsibility for it. And Jenna, you shared how to properly clean a microwave. And many people wrote in about it, lady. Really?
太棒了。但这确实很有趣。它在多种语言里都很有趣。哦，另一个人们非常喜欢的故事情节是关于厨房里脏兮兮的微波炉，以及没有人想清理它或为此负责。珍娜，你分享了如何正确清洁微波炉。很多人为此写信给我们，女士。真的吗？
Yes. Mike F from Canada said, I never thought I'd say this. but thanks to Jenna and Office Ladies, my microwave is now nice and clean. Well, you're very welcome. You know, lady, we also got a lot of folks who wrote in because they loved your idea to call our mom detectives show Bush Hiders because of how we said we might have to hide in bushes on a stakeout.
是的。来自加拿大的迈克·F 说，我从没想过我会这么说，但多亏了珍娜和《办公室女士》，我的微波炉现在又干净又漂亮了。好吧，不客气。你知道吗，女士，还有很多人写信给我们，因为他们喜欢你提议把我们的妈妈侦探节目叫作“灌木丛躲藏者”，因为我们说过在监视时可能不得不躲在灌木丛里。
J. said, I'm tardy to the Office Ladies podcast party, but got to this episode today, and I'm literally cracking up at everything bush hiders. You two are amazing and my cheeks hurt from laughing. Thank you. Needed this. And Alessandra S. said, is there a bush hiders yet?
J 说，我参加《办公室女士》播客派对迟到了，但今天听到了这一集，我真的被“灌木丛躲藏者”这个梗笑死了。你们俩太棒了，我笑得脸颊都疼了。谢谢。我需要这个。亚历山德拉·S 说，已经有“灌木丛躲藏者”了吗？
I completely forgotten about this bush hiders conversation. That really cracks me up. Can you imagine? Can you imagine us going into some big TV studio and being like, We've got the show for you. It's called Bush Hiders. I think we'd sell it. Oh, my gosh.
我完全忘了这个“灌木丛躲藏者”的对话了。这真的让我笑个不停。你能想象吗？你能想象我们走进某个大型电视演播室说，我们有个节目给你们，叫《灌木丛躲藏者》。我想我们会卖掉它的。哦，天哪。
I think it would sell in the room. Oh, my goodness. Well, that was a real joy. Well, everyone, this episode is full of all kinds of fun stuff. And so now, without any further ado, here is our second drink of Framed Toby. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together.
我觉得在房间里就能卖出去。哦，天哪。好吧，那真是太开心了。好了，各位，这一集充满了各种有趣的东西。那么现在，废话不多说，这是我们的第二杯《Framed Toby》。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi, Angela. Hello, lady. We're not in the studio together today, are we?
我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。嗨，安吉拉。你好，女士。我们今天没在同一个演播室，对吧？
We're not. But you look like you're in a fancy studio? I am in the fancy New York offices of Stitcher. Get out. You're in New York City. Yeah. And guess what, lady? What?
没有。但你看上去像是在一个高级演播室里？我是在 Stitcher 位于纽约的高级办公室里。别开玩笑了。你在纽约市。是的。而且你猜怎么着，女士？什么？
Guess what? What? Our picture is on the wall here. In New York? Yes. In the New York offices. They have our office lady's picture on the wall. I took a picture with it.
猜怎么着？什么？我们的照片挂在这里的墙上。在纽约？是的。在纽约办公室。他们把我们的《办公室女士》照片挂在墙上。我和它合了影。
Ah, that's so cool. I know. We have photos in two cities. In two cities, that's the big time. We're bicostal. We are. Wait a second. Right now we're bicostal.
啊，那太酷了。我知道。我们在两个城市都有照片。在两个城市，那可是大场面。我们是跨东西海岸的。我们是。等等。现在我们是跨东西海岸的。
Office ladies has gone bicostal. That feels real boss lady. It does. I like it. Me too. Well, since we're talking about being in offices, Jenna, guess who's back Dunder Mifflin. Toby.
《办公室女士》已经跨东西海岸了。感觉真像个老板。确实。我喜欢。我也是。好吧，既然我们在谈论办公室，珍娜，猜猜谁回到了邓德·米夫林。托比。
Well, not everybody's happy about it. No, God! No, God! Please, no! No! No! No! That's right.
好吧，并不是每个人都为此感到高兴。不，上帝！不，上帝！求你了，不！不！不！不！没错。
Today we are talking about Frame Toby. It is Season 5, Episode 9. It is written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Jason Reitman. That's a good duo. I'm going to give you a summary. I was hoping you would. Michael reacts poorly to the revelation that Toby is back at the Scranton branch. I like the use of the word poorly.
今天我们要谈论的是《Framed Toby》。这是第五季第九集。由敏迪·卡灵编剧，杰森·雷特曼执导。那是个不错的组合。我来给你做个总结。我正希望你这么做。迈克尔对托比回到斯克兰顿分部的消息反应很差。我喜欢“反应很差”这个词。
I know. That's an understatement. So he and Dwight hatch a plan to frame Toby for drugs that Michael has purchased from the two Vance refrigeration employees, Gino and Leo. Pam is incensed by a mess that is left in the microwave by one of her coworkers, we don't know who. She leaves a pointed note, which elicits mixed reactions from the fellow employees. Meanwhile, Ryan breaks up with Kelly and Jim surprises Pam with the news that he bought his parents' house for them. That's a lot. It's a lot.
我知道。那还是轻描淡写。所以他和德怀特策划了一个计划，要把迈克尔从两名万斯制冷员工吉诺和里奥那里买来的毒品栽赃给托比。帕姆对其中一名同事留在微波炉里的烂摊子感到愤怒，我们不知道是谁。她留下了一张尖锐的字条，引起了同事们的不同反应。与此同时，瑞安和凯利分手了，吉姆给了帕姆一个惊喜，告诉她他为他们买了父母的房子。那信息量很大。确实很大。
These headphones are tight. The headphones are tight in New York. I fixed them. Do you want a different pair? No, I fixed them. You guys, that was Jared in New York. Yeah. Jared is the Sam of New York. Yeah, Sam say hi.
这些耳机太紧了。在纽约耳机很紧。我调好了。你想要另一副吗？不，我调好了。伙计们，那是纽约的贾里德。是的。贾里德就是纽约的萨姆。是的，萨姆打个招呼。
A little dig at L.A. there in our loose headphones. Why? I think she likes some loose. I like a loose headphones. Oh, in that case, take that, Jared. Jared's all squeezing my brain with the headphones here in New York. Should we go into Fast Facts? I think we should.
对洛杉矶耳机松垮的一点小挖苦。为什么？我想她喜欢松一点的。我喜欢松一点的耳机。哦，那样的话，接着吧，贾里德。贾里德在纽约用耳机挤压我的大脑。我们应该进入“快速事实”环节吗？我想我们应该。
All right. Fast fact number one, you might remember because we shared this earlier, that NBC ordered 28 episodes for season five. It was our longest season. I remember, Jenna, when we wrapped season five, we all got sick. Oh, yeah. Like, we all got the flu or something. Because I remember the next week, like, texting a few people, I'm like, I have a cold. Kate was like, yeah, me too.
好的。快速事实第一条，你可能还记得，因为我们之前分享过，NBC 为第五季预订了 28 集。这是我们最长的一季。我记得，珍娜，当我们结束第五季拍摄时，我们都病倒了。哦，是的。就像，我们都得了流感什么的。因为我记得接下来的一周，给几个人发短信，我说，我感冒了。凯特说，是的，我也是。
Like, I think our bodies were just like, yeah. Yeah. A standard network television season usually runs on television from September to May. We work from July to March, right, so that we can get the episodes ready. And a standard television schedule is usually where you do three weeks on, one week off, of filming. So usually a show will take one hiatus week a month. But the writers always continue to work for that week. That week off is meant so that the writers and the producer, they have a sort of catch-up week.
就像，我觉得我们的身体都在说，够了。是的。标准的电视网剧集通常从九月到五月在电视上播出。我们从七月工作到三月，对吧，这样我们才能准备好剧集。标准的电视时间表通常是拍摄三周，休息一周。所以通常一个节目每个月会有一个停播周。但编剧们在那一周总是继续工作。那一周的休息是为了让编剧和制片人有一个补课周。
Because they're constantly writing, prepping, editing, delivering the episodes. They would have these episodes in multiple forms. They're like doing an outline for one, but they're writing another. They're punching up another one. They're doing post-editing on another one. They've got like five episodes going at once. We would just be like, what are we filming this week? Right.
因为他们一直在写作、筹备、剪辑、交付剧集。他们会以多种形式处理这些剧集。他们就像是在为一部写大纲，但同时在写另一部。他们在润色另一部。他们在对另一部进行后期剪辑。他们同时有五部剧集在进行。我们只会说，我们这周拍什么？对。
This year with this crazy 28 episode season, Steve Correll also had a commitment to do a film. I think it was Get Smart. And he needed like a six to eight week break from the show in the middle of that July to March filming schedule so he could film Get Smart. How did we ever do that? In order to do that, we had to film 19 episodes in a row. That's when we got sick. That's when we got sick.
今年有这疯狂的 28 集，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔也有拍电影的承诺。我想是《糊涂侦探》。他在七月到三月的拍摄计划中间需要大约六到八周的休息时间，这样他才能去拍《糊涂侦探》。我们是怎么做到的？为了做到这一点，我们不得不连续拍摄 19 集。那就是我们病倒的时候。那就是我们病倒的时候。
I just have a memory of a bunch of us getting a cold buck. That was it. Yeah. So Frame Toby was right in the middle of this crazy 19 episode schedule. Oyo, yoy. And here's why I think this is significant. It's really crazy to me that they decided to bring Toby back in the middle of this 19 episode stretch. Because remember, he was now our showrunner because Greg was doing Parks and Rec.
我只记得我们一群人感冒了。就是那样。是的。所以《Framed Toby》正好处于这疯狂的 19 集拍摄计划中间。哎哟，哎哟。这就是为什么我认为这很重要。他们决定在这 19 集的中间让托比回来，这对我来说真的很疯狂。因为记住，他当时是我们的剧集主管，因为格雷格在做《公园与游憩》。
So Paul Lieberstein is now show running and acting in an episode. Again, because they gave him that break. And now they're like, sorry, bud, you need to be Toby again. You're back in the mix. So I reached out to Jen Salada, who was running the show with him. And I said, do you know why you did that? Did you just want Paul to never sleep? What was your plan there?
所以保罗·利伯斯坦现在既是剧集主管又在这一集中表演。再次强调，因为他们给了他那个休息时间。现在他们说，抱歉，伙计，你需要再次成为托比。你又回到了混合中。所以我联系了和他一起管理节目的简·萨拉塔。我说，你知道你们为什么要那样做吗？你们只是想让保罗永远不睡觉吗？你们当时的计划是什么？
And she said, she can't remember exactly the reasoning. But because Holly had left, they were either going to have to cast someone new or bring Toby back. And that dynamic between Toby and Michael was so beloved. She said, as a fan of the show, she wanted Toby to come back to that role. As a co-show runner, she was freaked out at the idea of Paul having. to wear both hats, but she said he did it so well. And Paul said he doesn't remember sleeping a lot. Aw. But also, he enjoyed doing it. You know, he liked his time on set with us. Well, I love Toby coming back just because watching Michael Spiral is delicious.
她说，她记不清具体原因了。但因为霍莉离开了，他们要么得选个新人，要么得让托比回来。托比和迈克尔之间的那种动态太受欢迎了。她说，作为节目的粉丝，她希望托比回到那个角色。作为联合主管，她对保罗不得不身兼两职的想法感到惊恐，但她说他做得非常好。保罗说他不记得睡过很多觉。啊。但同时，他很享受这样做。你知道，他喜欢和我们在片场的时间。好吧，我喜欢托比回来，仅仅是因为看着迈克尔崩溃太美妙了。
This is one of my favorite episodes of the season for that reason. So thank you, Paul, for doing that. For Paul, but thank you. My fast fact number two is a big thank you. to James Carey because he gave us the shooting draft for Frame Toby. Yes, James. This was so fun to watch it with the shooting draft. Jenna and I were texting each other and calling each other like, oh, my God, that's not in. Oh, but this is. But did you see that?
这是我本季最喜欢的剧集之一，原因就在这里。所以谢谢你，保罗，这样做。为了保罗，但谢谢你。我的快速事实第二条是一个大大的感谢，给詹姆斯·凯里，因为他给了我们《Framed Toby》的拍摄剧本。是的，詹姆斯。看着拍摄剧本看这一集太有趣了。珍娜和我互相发短信打电话说，哦，天哪，那没在里面。哦，但这个在。但你看到了吗？
It was really fun. And this is a particularly amazing episode to have the script for it because this microwave runner, the dirty microwave runner, it was much bigger in the original script. Yes. And it was full of Angela and Pam's stuff. Yes, so we get to share about all that today. So thank you, James Carey. Thank you, James Carey. We are also going to have some great location details thanks to Randy Cordray. He told me all about Jim and Pam's new house. And I have to share something that Randy said in his email to me when I reached out to him about this episode. Are you ready?
这真的很有趣。而且这一集有剧本特别棒，因为这个微波炉的梗，那个脏微波炉的梗，在原始剧本里要大得多。是的。而且全是安吉拉和帕姆的东西。是的，所以我们今天可以分享所有这些。所以谢谢你，詹姆斯·凯里。谢谢你，詹姆斯·凯里。多亏了兰迪·科德雷，我们还将有一些很棒的地点细节。他告诉了我所有关于吉姆和帕姆新房子的事。当我联系他询问这一集时，我必须分享兰迪在邮件里说的一些话。准备好了吗？
Okay, yes. He said, a particular delight of looking forward to your questions each week is that I get to revisit each other. episode to refresh my memory of what we collectively accomplished. Here's what his process is when I write him an email. Oh. He says, my process is to reread the shooting draft, watch the episode, watch any deleted scenes, and listen to any commentary that might have been recorded. Randy, this is what I do every week. This is what Jen and I are doing. That's what I said. I said, you are an office lady. You are an office lady. And Jenna, every time you email me, a question now. I'm going to be like, don't ask him that. I don't want to send him down a rabbit hole. I know, but he really said he's really been liking it. And remember when our podcast for weight
好的，是的。他说，每周期待你们的问题的一个特别乐趣是，我可以重温每一集，刷新我对我们共同完成的事情的记忆。这是我给他写邮件时他的流程。哦。他说，我的流程是重读拍摄剧本，观看剧集，观看任何删除的场景，并听取可能录制的任何评论。兰迪，这就是我每周做的。这就是简和我正在做的。我就是这么说的。我说，你是一位《办公室女士》。你是一位《办公室女士》。珍娜，现在你每次给我发邮件问问题。我都会想，别问他那个。我不想让他掉进兔子洞。我知道，但他真的说他一直很喜欢。还记得我们的播客关于减肥的那一集出来时，兰迪给我们写了那封邮件吗？他给我们写了最可爱的邮件。是的。他就像是，女士们，你们做到了。你们得到了关于我们如何用雨水和停车场拍摄那个订婚场景的所有可能知道的信息。我为你们俩感到骄傲。我知道。就像我们收到了爸爸的邮件。我就是那种感觉。就像爸爸觉得我们做得很好。我知道。我想要兰迪的尊重。我也想要，因为我尊重他。看看他在做什么。仅仅是一封问题邮件。我们得让他上节目。他必须来。他是一位《办公室女士》。我们需要让兰迪和詹姆斯来。是的。因为他们一起工作。好的。未来重温，大家。你们听到了吗，兰迪和詹姆斯？我想那是我的严肃语气。我在做什么？你们听到了吗？你们要来播客了，伙计们。我要带我们进入快速事实第三条。好的。我想全世界都会感谢这个快速事实，因为我很感激它。哦，不。有人做了深入研究。这是如何清洁微波炉。哦，天哪。这一集是关于脏微波炉的。我想，我们怎么能清洁这个微波炉？这一集是关于脏微波炉的。好的，安斯利·布比科，
loss came out and Randy wrote us that night's email? He wrote us the most lovely email. Yeah. He was just like, ladies, you nailed it. You got every bit of information that could be known about how we did that engagement scene with the rain and the parking lot. I'm so proud of you, too. I know. It was like we got an email from our dad. That's how I felt. Like dad thought we did a good job. I know. I want Randy's respect. I do too because I respect him. Look what he's doing. Just off an email of questions. We got to have him on the show. He's got to come on. He's an office lady. We need to have Randy and James come on. Yes. Because they worked together. Okay. Future revisited everybody. Did you hear that Randy and James? I guess that's my serious tone. What am I doing? Did you hear that? You're coming on the pod, fellas. I'm going to move us into Fast fact number three. Okay. I think the world is going to be. grateful for this fast fact because I was grateful for it. Oh, no. Somebody did a deep dive. This is how to clean a microwave. Oh, Lord. This episode's about dirty microwaves. And I thought, how could we clean this microwave? This episode is about dirty microwaves. All right, Ainsley Bubicoe,
我们的助理制片人，帮了我这个忙，我喜欢它。这是清洁一个真正脏的微波炉的方法。好的。好的。拿一个微波炉安全的碗。装上两杯水和两汤匙醋。现在，顺便说一句，如果你愿意，你可以加一滴你最喜欢的精油，如果你想的话。如果你想变得高级一点。是的。你可以高级地或普通地清洁你的微波炉。好的。现在，打开微波炉，显然，把碗放进微波炉，然后调到高火五分钟。
our associate producer, helped me with this and I love it. Here is how to clean a real dirty microwave. Okay. All right. Get a microwave safe bowl. Fill it with two cups of water and two tablespoons of vinegar. Now, side note, if you'd like, you could add a drop of your favorite essential oil, if you want. If you want to be fancy. Yeah. You can clean your microwave fancy or regular. Okay. Now, turn the microwave on, obviously, put the bowl in the microwave and then put it on high for five minutes.
你想让里面真的充满蒸汽。好的。这就是她说的。结束后，不要打开微波炉门 15 分钟。为什么？因为你会烫伤自己什么的？不，因为那会让所有烤干的污垢变软。然后你就可以擦掉它了？是的，那是第三步。
You want it to get real steamy in there. Okay. That's what she said. After it's done, don't open the microwave door for 15 minutes. Why? Because you'll burn yourself or something? No, because that makes all the baked on grime sort of soften. And then you can wipe it off? Yeah, that's step three.
擦掉它。只要擦掉就行。完成了。你的微波炉干净了。不客气。不客气。就是这样。我们可以去休息了。
Wipe it off. Just wipe it out. Done. Your microwave is clean. You're welcome. You're welcome. That's it. We can go to break.
你可以在听广告的时候清洁你的微波炉。或者如果你在 Stitcher Premium 上收听，你将没有时间清洁你的微波炉，因为它是无广告的。哦。好吧，让我们休息一下，因为珍娜刚才告诉我纽约的洗手间离你坐的地方真的很远。确实很远，而且你需要一把钥匙。哦。是的。
You can clean your microwave while you listen to some advertisements. Or if you're listening on Stitcher Premium, You won't have time to clean your microwave because it's ad-free. Oh. Well, let's take a break because Jinda just told me the bathrooms in New York are real far from where you're sitting. They are and you need a key. Oh. Yeah.
好吧，在洛杉矶，那是路边的移动厕所。所以我得去了。开玩笑的。萨姆在鼓掌。好了，伙计们。我们马上回来。我们马上回来。如果你们在历史课上学到的一切都只是故事的一半呢？
Well, in L.A., it's a porta-potty on the side of the road. So I'm going to go. I'm kidding. Sam is applauding. All right, guys. We'll be right back. We'll be right back. What if everything you learned in history class was only half the story?
我是赫里尼·博特博士，《隐藏的历史》的主持人。每周一，我都会去历史变得神秘的地方，被放逐的文明、世界末日的预言、超自然现象，以及科学仍然无法完全解释的事件。在《隐藏的历史》中，我把这些时刻当作未结案件，而不是神话，不是迷信，只是等待仔细观察的不完整解释。收听并关注《隐藏的历史》，
I'm Dr. Hrini Bot, host of Hidden History. Every Monday, I go where history gets mysterious, banished civilizations, doomsday prophecies, paranormal phenomena, and events that science still can't fully explain. On Hidden History, I treat these moments like open case files, not miss, not superstition, just incomplete explanations waiting for a closer look. Listen to and follow Hidden History,
现在可以在你获取播客的任何地方收听。好吧，我们回来了，每个人都很兴奋，因为会议室里有布朗尼。每次我在办公室工作，有人带烘焙食品来，那都是一个令人兴奋的时刻。当然。我喜欢。我们不确定为什么会有布朗尼，但每个人都为此感到很高兴。这是真的。
available now wherever you get your podcasts. Well, we are back, and everyone's real excited because there's brownies in the conference room. Every time I worked in an office and someone brought in a baked good, it was a whole exciting moment. Heck yeah. I loved it. We're not sure why there are brownies, but everyone's real happy about it. It's true.
我们有一个来自杰西卡·L 的粉丝问题，她说，为什么在剧集开始时会议室里有布朗尼？是谁的生日吗？然后杰西卡想知道，是安吉拉带的布朗尼吗？因为我们听到了很多关于安吉拉著名布朗尼的提及。是的。好吧，我看了剧本。是的。
We had a fan question from Jessica L. that says, why are there brownies in the conference room at the beginning of episode? Was it someone's birthday? And then Jessica would like to know, did Angela bring the brownies? because we've heard a lot of references to Angela's famous brownies. Yeah. Well, I looked at the script. Yeah.
因为我有它。没错。上面写着菲利斯在分发布朗尼，但没有进一步解释原因。但它确实提到了安吉拉没有吃布朗尼。是的，在剧本里，帕姆说，安吉拉，你为什么不吃点？是的。帕姆，有点挑事。安迪说她在节食。
Because I had it. That's right. It says Phyllis is giving away brownies, but there is no further explanation as to why. But it does make a note that Angela is not eating the brownies. Yeah, in the script, Pam is like, Angela, why aren't you having any? Yeah. Pam, a little bit of a shi stir. Andy says she's dieting.
我的宝贝正试图穿进一件儿童尺寸的婚纱，为了我们的大日子。吉姆说，为什么，为什么会有那种东西存在？是的。然后安吉拉说，那是从我选美时期开始的。我 10 岁时是中大西洋小姐。什么？安吉拉的童年是什么样的？我不知道。
My baby's trying to fit into a child-sized wedding gown for our big day. And Jim says, why and why do those exist? Yeah. And then Angela says, it's from my pageant days. I was Miss Tiny Mid-Atlantic Bride when I was 10. What? Was Angela's childhood? I don't know.
说真的。伙计们，记住，这是一个呼应。记得第二季的《绩效评估》吗？安吉拉有一个谈话头，她说，我引用，我实际上很期待绩效评估。我参加过青少年选美巡回赛，我非常享受那个。我真的很喜欢被评判。我相信即使在严厉的审查下，我也表现得很好。
Seriously. And you guys, remember, this is a callback. Remember Performance Review Season 2? Angela had a talking head where she said, and I quote, I actually look forward to performance reviews. I did the Youth Beauty Pagent Circuit, and I enjoyed that quite a bit. I really enjoy being judged. I believe I hold up very well even to severe scrutiny.
好吧，我们知道你 10 岁时赢得了中大西洋小姐。那是我的婚纱。就是它。我想知道你还赢了多少个这样的奖项。我想知道，作为安吉拉这个角色，你心目中是个大赢家吗？你觉得她经常赢吗？是的。我觉得安吉拉·马丁在 13 岁时达到了巅峰。好的。就像她是最好的。她赢得了所有年轻选美、初级选美，然后她退休了。我明白了。好的。让我们继续。当我们在会议室时，凯利要拿两个
Well, we know that you won Miss Tiny Mid-Atlantic Bride when you were 10. And that's my wedding dress. There it is. I wonder how many more of these that you won. I wonder, were you a big winner in your mind as the kids? character of Angela. Do you think she won quite often? Yes. I think that Angela Martin like peaked at 13. Okay. Like she was it. She won all of like the young pageant, junior pageant, and then she retired. I see. Okay. Let us move on. While we're in the conference room, Kelly is going to take two
布朗尼。一个给托比。没错。迈克尔对此有点嗤之以鼻，但似乎没有其他人觉得这是个问题。是的，他叫她怪胎。他说，随便吧，怪胎。我知道。吉姆说，迈克尔，托比回来了。迈克尔说，好吧。所以他走回附楼，那里没人，但突然有人在那里。那是托比。那是托比。我想让你们知道，在 1 分 23 秒，当迈克尔转身看到托比，脸上露出那种惊恐的表情时，如果你看他身后的墙，你会看到墙上有三个托比的装裱东西。有一个托比·弗兰德森的奖项，一张成就证书，还有一张来自加州海岸学院的文凭。所以，珍娜，他回来得够久了，可以挂上他的装裱物品了。在剧本里，托比有一个谈话头，他说，我回来六天了。
brownies. One for Toby. Right. And Michael kind of scoffs at this, but nobody else seems to think it's a Yeah, he calls her a weirdo. He's like, whatever weirdo. I know. And Jim is like, Michael, Toby is back. And Michael's like, okay. And so he walks back to the annex and no one's there, but then suddenly someone is there. And it is Toby. It is Toby. I want you guys to know at one minute, 23 seconds, as Michael turns to see Toby and he has that look of horror in his face, if you look at the wall behind him, you will see that there are three framed sort of things on the wall for Toby. There is an award for Toby Flanderson, a certificate of achievement, and a diploma from the California Coastal College. So, Jenna, he had been back long enough to hang up his framed items. And in the script, Toby had a talking head where he said this, I've been back for six days.
我想我甚至和他说过话。我希望那段保留下来。我也是。我非常希望它保留下来。对于我的背景捕捉者们，加州海岸学院，我不认为有这个东西。我谷歌了一下。我没找到。我找到了加州海岸大学，那是一所位于加利福尼亚州圣安娜的私立在线大学。
I think I've even talked to him. I wish that stayed in. Me too. I wish so much it had stayed in. For my background, catch folks, the California Coastal College, I don't think that's the thing. I googled it. I couldn't find it. I did find the California Coast University, which is a private online university based in Santa Ana, California.
哦。给你，我的背景调查员们。好吧，我们收到了很多粉丝来信。人们想知道迈克尔尖叫“不”以及所有这些是即兴创作的还是剧本里的。在剧本里，它只是说迈克尔转身尖叫，用大写字母。是的。但那种“不，不，上帝，不”，那是史蒂夫。那是史蒂夫对那个剧本注释的诠释。
Oh. There you go, my background, people. Well, we got a lot of fan mail. People wanted to know if Michael's screaming no and all of that was improvised or if it was in the script. In the script, it just says Michael turns and screams in all caps. Yeah. But that whole like, no, no, God, no, that was Steve. That was Steve's interpretation of that script note.
那有多好笑？伙计们，如果你读到你尖叫，我想我们大多数人只会说，啊，对吧？是的。但史蒂夫把那一刻发挥得淋漓尽致。以最好的方式。他是喜剧天才。是的。你知道 Screen Rant 做了一个列表。
And how funny was that? You guys, if you read that you scream, I think most of us would just be like, ah, right? Yes. But Steve made a meal out of that moment. In the best way. He's a comedy genius. Yes. You know, Screen Rant did a list.
关于《办公室》创造的 15 大流行文化参考，史蒂夫说“不”的表情包就是其中之一。我不怀疑。我在网上看到我甚至不认识的人，回应别人时只用史蒂夫那张说“不”的脸。太棒了。好吧，剧集开始了，迈克尔正在崩溃。他要给大卫·华莱士打电话，他看着愚蠢的托比向菲利斯展示他愚蠢的哥斯达黎加照片。是的，他通过给大卫发短信“911，给我打电话”成功联系上了他。但你知道吗？迈克尔说他学到，除非他发短信“911”，否则人们不会回他的电话。现在每个人都回了，因为他们以为发生了什么可怕的事情。
of the top 15 pop culture references created by the office, and the meme of Steve saying no is one of them. I don't doubt it. I've been online where I see people that I don't even know, like respond to other people would just Steve's face going, no. It's amazing. Well, the episode starts and Michael is spiraling. He's going to call David Wallace. He's watching stupid Toby as he shows his stupid photos of Costa Rica to Phyllis. Yeah, he manages to get David on the phone by texting him 911. Call me. But you know what? Michael said he's learned that people will not return his calls unless he texts 911. And now everybody does because they think something horrible has happened.
我刚到洛杉矶时有一个寻呼机。我也是。你必须有。因为你没有真正的手机。你有一个寻呼机。你拥有寻呼机的唯一原因是为了让你的经纪人可以在你得到试镜时呼叫你。然后你必须去找一部电话。
I had a pager when I first got to L.A. So did I. You had to. Because you didn't like really have cell phones. You had a pager. And the only reason you had a pager was so that your agent could page you if, you had to You got an audition. And then you would have to go find a phone.
你必须找到一部公用电话。然后回电。是的。我曾经在车里放一个装满零钱的拉链袋，原因有两个。第一，为了所有不接受信用卡、只收硬币的计费停车位。第二，为了当我经纪人呼叫我时，我可以找到一部公用电话回电，那可能一年两次。哦，是的。我清楚地记得有一次，我和朋友们开车经过圣莫尼卡。
You'd have to find a pay phone. And call them back. Yeah. I used to keep a Ziploc bag full of change in my car for two reasons. One, for all of the metered parking that didn't accept credit cards, just coins. And two, so that I could find a pay phone and call my agent back when my agent paged me, which was maybe twice a year. Oh, yeah. I remember one time distinctly, I was driving through Santa Monica with some friends.
我的寻呼机响了，我差点冲出路面。因为我想，我的事业要开始了。我进入大场面了。我被呼叫了。我们本该去海滩的。我说，不，我们现在不能那样做了。我必须找到一部公用电话。所以我们都在街上开车寻找公用电话。
and my pager went off and I almost swerved off the road. Because I was like, my career is happening. I've hit the big time. I've been paged. We were supposed to be going to the beach. I was like, no, we can't do that now. I have to find a pay phone. So we're all like driving the streets looking for a pay phone.
我靠边停车。我跑到公用电话前。我投了硬币。给他们打电话。他们说，好吧。你曾经需要任何种类的眼镜吗？我说，什么？不。
I pulled over. I ran up to the pay phone. I put my corridors in. Called them. And they were like, all right. Have you ever needed any kind of glasses? I'm like, what? No.
他们说，我们有一个试镜，为你，为 Lens Crafters。他们想要戴眼镜的人。我说，那不是我。好吧。再见。是的。差不多就是这样。但后来我确实有一个男朋友，他没有回我电话。你点亮那个寻呼机了吗？我确实用一堆 911 点亮了它。你知道的。你真的做了吗？哦，是的。哦，是的。我做了。你是个疯狂的女朋友吗？你知道吗？他那天晚上在背着我偷情。哦，所以你知道。你知道。我知道。在那之后我们分手了。哦，天哪。是的。我不会点亮寻呼机。我坐在这里叫你疯子。我不会点亮寻呼机，但我会开车过去，躲在灌木丛里。那比发短信 911 要复杂得多。这是我的计划。我想，我知道他在背着我偷情。
And they're like, we have an audition. for you for lens crafters. They would like people who wear glasses. I'm like, that's not me. All right. Bye. Yeah. That's pretty much it. But then I did have a boyfriend once who was not calling me back. Did you light up that pager? I sure did with a bunch of 911s. You know it. Did you really? Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. I did. Were you a psycho girlfriend? You know what? He was chival. cheating on me that night. Oh, so you knew. You knew. I knew it. We broke up after that. Oh, man. Yeah. I wouldn't light up the pager. I'm like sitting here calling you Psycho. I wouldn't light up the pager, but I would drive over and like hide out in a bush. That's so much more elaborate than texting 911. Here was my plan. I was like, I know he's cheating on me.
所以我打算点亮那个寻呼机，让它嗡嗡作响，这样当他们在做任何事时，寻呼机就会响。你就像，叮，叮。是的。我只是要毁掉他们的好时光。他可能只是把它关掉了。我想我只是要从灌木丛里跳出来说，嘿，你在做什么？抓到你了。现在我要回家了，因为我头发里有树枝，而且我很尴尬。
So I am going to light up that pager and make it buzz so that while they're whatever they're doing, the page is. You're just like, zing, zing. Yeah. I'm just going to ruin their good time. He probably just turned it off. I guess I'm just going to jump out of a bush and be like, hey, what do you do it? Gotcha. Now I'm going to go home because I've got twigs in my hair and I'm embarrassed.
这是“妈妈侦探”的情节吗？我们应该把“妈妈侦探”设定在过去，那时我们只有寻呼机和躲在灌木丛里吗？是的。哦，灌木丛躲藏。哎呀。那可能是别的东西。这有什么问题吗？我们可以叫它《灌木丛躲藏者》吗？
Is this a plot line for mom detectives? Should we set mom detectives in the past where all we have are pagers and bush hiding? Yes. Oh, bush hiding. Uh-oh. That could be something else. What's wrong with this? Can we call it Bush Hiders?
不。我们不能。它甚至没有任何意义。它没有任何意义。你去推销它。嗨，我们的节目。它叫《灌木丛躲藏者》。如果你不想买它，你就是个混蛋。
No. We can't. It doesn't even make any sense. It doesn't make any sense. You go pitch it. Hi, our show. It's called Bush Hiders. And if you don't want to buy it, you're an asshole.
因为这是金子。他们说，它是关于什么的？我们说，这是两个妈妈侦探。这是两个穿着舒适衣服的老年女性。是的，我们没穿任何名牌衣服。我们想要 30 分钟的服装环节。它不会是合身的。
Because this is gold. And they're like, what's it about? And we're like, it's two mom detectives. It's two older women and comfortable clothing. Yeah, we're not wearing any designer clothes. We want like 30-minute wore. wardrobe sessions. It won't be fitted.
我们想要很多没人会真正理解的旧技术。我们要躲在一些灌木丛里。是的。你想要吗？好的。我们在哪？我们不应该在广播里分享这个，因为有人会偷走它。我向你保证，两年内。
And we want a lot of old tech that no one watching it will really understand. And we're going to hide in some bushes. Yeah. Do you want it? Okay. Where are we? We shouldn't have shared that on the air because someone's going to steal it. I guarantee you in two years.
你会打开 HBO Max，会有两个 20 岁的人主演一个叫《灌木丛躲藏者》的节目。记住我的话。记住我的话。他们会是年轻、火辣的侦探，穿着名牌衣服。这就是这个行业的运作方式。没错。我没有厌世。好的。我们应该继续吗？我在纽约发生了什么？我在这里是谁？我不知道。你刚喝了一大口咖啡，你说，这就是这个行业的运作方式。好吧，听着，你知道吗？大卫·华莱士告诉迈克尔他只能处理它。是的。他不敢相信他的一个员工回来这么久，他竟然不知道。
You're going to turn on HBO Max and there's going to be two 20-year-old starring in a show called Bush Hiders. Mark my word. Mark my word. And they're going to be young, hot detectives and designer clothes. That's how it works in this business. That's right. I'm not jaded. All right. Should we move on? What's happening to me in New York? Who am I here? I don't know. You just took a big swig of coffee and you're like, that's how it works in the business. Well, listen, you know what? David Wallace tells Michael he's just going to have to deal with it. Yeah. And he couldn't believe that one of his employees had been back so long and he didn't know.
德怀特和迈克尔让他知道附楼很恶心。后面很恶心。是的。他真的希望大卫除掉托比。大卫说，没有理由我不能除掉他。迈克尔说他有理由。是因为我恨他。因为。
And Dwight and Michael let him know that the annex is icky. It's icky back there. Yeah. And he really wants David to get rid of Toby. And David says, I can't get rid of him without cause. And Michael says he has cause. It's because I hate him. Because.
但这显然不是理由。好吧，他们会找到什么的。但珍娜，另一个问题正在发生。是的。这是办公室里充满戏剧性的一天。帕姆在厨房准备食物。她发现了微波炉里的烂摊子。珍娜？
But that is not obviously cause. Well, they're going to find something. But Jenna, another issue is happening. Yeah. It's a day of drama in the office. Pam is preparing food in the kitchen. and she discovers a mess in the microwave. Jenna?
是的。你看到帕姆在准备什么了吗？我知道帕姆在准备什么。分享一下。这可能是我最常被问到的问题之一，除了茶壶字条里写了什么。不可能。是的。人们问，在脏微波炉那一集里，帕姆在微波炉里加热什么？
Yeah. Did you see what Pam was preparing? I know what Pam was preparing. Share. This is maybe one of my most frequently asked questions outside of what was in the teapot note. No way. Yes. People are like, what is Pam microwaving in the episode with the dirty microwave?
这里有一些猜测。我们收到了邮件。这是人们猜测我在微波炉里加热的东西。好的。苹果汁。嗯。益生菌饮料。好的。
Here are some guesses. We got mail. Here are what people are guessing that I was microwaving. Okay. Apple juice. Hmm. A probiotic drink. Okay.
蛋清。骨汤。嗯。汤、牛奶、粥和酸奶。好吧，我不知道，所以我看了剧本。但是，珍娜，你告诉我们。是蛋清。是蛋清，顺便说一句，了解我现实生活中的闺蜜，我觉得这很合适。
Egg whites. Bone broth. Hmm. Soup, milk, porridge, and yogurt. Well, I had no idea, so I looked at the script. But, Jenna, you tell us. It's egg whites. It's egg whites, which I, by the way, knowing my BFF in real life, thought was kind of fitting.
是的。因为你可以买这些小杯装的蛋清，那就是她在做的。她要给自己微波一些蛋清。很多人也问微波炉里有什么。那也在剧本里。嗯哼。它只是说像一团酱汁烂摊子，基本上。我把它打出来了。
Yeah. Because you can buy egg whites in these little cups, and that's what she's doing. She's going to microwave herself some egg whites. A lot of people also asked what was in the microwave. That is also in the script. Mm-hmm. And it just says like a saucy mess, basically. I typed it out.
它说，帕姆打开微波炉门放进一些蛋清，但微波炉里到处都是红酱汁。是的。现在我们在休息室。我们该给这个起什么标题？吉姆在休息室暴露了。不，那听起来不好。在休息室。
It says, Pam opens the microwave door to put in some egg whites, but the microwave is splattered all over with red sauce. Yeah. Now we're in the break room. And what would we title this? Jim's exposed in the break room. No, that doesn't sound good. in the break room.
休息室里的暴露。安迪，我想，有像鹰一样的眼睛。读了吉姆的邮件，发现吉姆在买他父母的房子，还没告诉帕姆。是的。或者正如凯文所说，他以前尿床的那栋房子。菲利斯觉得这很浪漫。直到她问吉姆它在哪里，吉姆说是林登大道。菲利斯做了一个鬼脸。
Exposure in the break room. Andy, I guess, has peepers like a hawk. And read Jim's email and found out that Jim is buying his parents' house and hasn't told Pam. Yeah. Or as Kevin puts it, the same house he used to pee the bed in. Phyllis thinks it's romantic. Until she asked Jim where it is, Jim says it's on Lyndon Ave. And Phyllis makes a face.
然后在背景里，你看到我翻了个白眼，就像，哦。我查了斯克兰顿的林登大道。我没找到林登大道。我找到了林登街，但它有点像在市中心。那里有商店和教堂，附近绝对没有采石场。哦。有趣。我们收到了很多问题，例如，来自布列塔尼·Y 和詹纳·B。他们用谁的房子作为吉姆父母的房子？内部是一个布景，还是他们用于外部的实际房子？这就是兰迪·科德雷真正为我做到的地方，安吉。带回家吧，兰迪。我记得那是两栋不同的房子。
And then in the background, you see me kind of roll my eyes like, ooh. I looked up Lyndon Ave in Scranton. I couldn't find a Lyndon Ave. I found a Lyndon Street, but it's sort of like in the heart of the city. There's like shops and churches and definitely no quarry nearby. Oh. Interesting. We got a lot of questions from, for example, Brittany Y and Jenner B. Whose house did they use for Jim's parents' house? Was the interior a set or was it the actual house that they used for the exterior? This is where Randy Cordray really came through for me, Ange. Bring it home, Randy. I remembered that it was two different houses.
我们用了一栋做内部，一栋做外部。兰迪说我们的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大找到了几个选择，兰迪真的很希望他们能找到一个单一的住所，既能做内部又能做外部，仅仅是因为在一个地点拍摄会容易得多。但没能那样。兰迪说他们看的一切要么适合内部但不适合外部，反之亦然。所以对于外部，我们使用了加利福尼亚州范奈斯卡尔弗特街的一栋有人居住的房子。但内部不适合拍摄。
We used one for the interior and one for the exterior. And Randy said that our location manager, Kyle Alexander, had found several choices and that Randy had really hoped that they could find a single residence that they could do both interior and exterior, just because it would be so much easier to shoot at just one location. But it didn't work out that way. Randy said everything they looked at either worked for the interior but not the exterior or vice versa. So for the exterior, we used an occupied home on Calvert Street in Van Nuys, California. But the interior was not suitable to shoot.
这是因为里面绝对可爱。而且它需要看起来有点破旧。是的，它太可爱了。当我们拍摄时，他们会让约翰和我走进房子，稍微补补妆，但我们只会站在前门里面，然后我们又会回到外面。就是这样。里面很可爱。哦，天哪。里面太可爱了。它装饰得像，哦，像一位英语教授的家。就像，舒适、文学书架，只是美丽的、某种修复过的家。太棒了。
This was because it was absolutely adorable inside. And it needed to look a little janky. Yeah, it was so cute. And when we were shooting there, they would let John and I step in to, the house to kind of get our makeup refreshed and touched up, but we would just stand right inside that front door, and then we would go back outside again. And that was it. And it was cute inside. Oh, my God. It was so cute. It was decorated like, oh, like an English professor's home. Like, just cozy, literary bookshelves, just beautiful, kind of restored home inside. So great.
我有一次在这个叫《Haders Back Off》的节目上也做过类似的事。我们在一栋房子里拍外部，在另一栋拍内部。当我们拍摄外部时，天气很冷，有点雾蒙蒙的雨。他们让我们走进前厅。是的，一样。我们等了，对吧？是的。我们根本没有走遍他们的房子，但我们走进了前厅。
I did something similar one time on this show called Haders Back Off. We filmed the exterior in one house and the interior and another. And when we were filming the exterior, it was cold and kind of misty raining. And they let us step inside just the front room. Yeah, same. We waited, right? Yeah. We didn't go throughout their house at all, but we stepped in the front room.
有一次我在一个叫《Haders Back Off》的节目里也做过类似的事。我们在一栋房子里拍外景，在另一栋房子里拍内景。拍外景的时候，天气很冷，还下着毛毛雨。他们让我们进了前厅避雨。没错，我也是。我们就在那儿等着，对吧？是的。我们根本没在他们家里到处走动，只是进了前厅而已。
And I was with Steve Little, and we weren't really sure what to expect. We opened the door to step in. And there was maybe 4,000 tiny dolls. What? Yes. What? There were dolls and cases, all kinds of fancy dolls in every kind of case you could imagine. Cases on the wall, little case stand on the ground.
我和史蒂夫·利特尔在一起，我们真的不知道会发生什么。我们打开门走进去。里面可能有4000个小玩偶。什么？是的。什么？到处都是玩偶和盒子，各种你能想象到的盒子，墙上有盒子，地上有小盒子架。
They were everywhere. And Steve and I stood right on the other side of the door and we're like, okay, so somebody likes dolls. Oh my gosh. I would be like, run. I know. Run now. I was like, okay, all right. If you have that many dolls, there's a very good chance that one of them is going to come alive and try to kill you.
它们无处不在。我和史蒂夫站在门边，心想，好吧，看来有人喜欢玩偶。天哪。我会说，快跑。我知道。现在就跑。我当时想，好吧，好吧。如果你有那么多玩偶，很有可能其中一个会活过来并试图杀了你。
I mean, if we've learned anything, one of them is possessed. One of them is possessed. And you know who's on the case? The mom detectives. The mom detectives. We got that covered. We got it covered. We'll hide in the bushes.
我的意思是，如果我们学到了什么，那就是其中一个被附身了。其中一个被附身了。你知道谁在调查吗？妈妈侦探。妈妈侦探。我们搞定了。我们搞定了。我们会躲在灌木丛里。
We'll figure it out. That's right. So this house was so cute. What Michael Gallenberg did, our set designer, he added a broken rain gutter to the outside. He changed the front door so that it would match the other location. Okay. where we go inside. And he also added that swinging screen door that bangs into the overhead awning.
我们会弄清楚的。没错。所以这房子太可爱了。我们的布景设计师迈克尔·加伦伯格在外面加了一个破损的雨水槽。他换了前门，以便与另一个拍摄地点匹配。好的。我们进去的地方。他还加了那个会撞到上方遮阳篷的纱门。
Oh, that was really funny. I know. And then they also asked the homeowner to turn off their sprinklers for a week leading up to the shoot to make the grass look kind of dry and weather beaten. And they did. They kind of killed their lawn for us. Thank you. Now, for the interior of Jim's parents' house and for the garage scenes, they found an unoccupied home on Allot, Aval which is also in Van Nuys. It was only a few blocks away from the other house. And for this one, they went in. They added the shag carpeting. They added the wood paneling. They changed the front door. Like they bought a front door and they put it on both houses so it would match, you know? So he was able to go in and completely set design the interior of the home. Is it A L-L-L-O-T-T-T-T? And you say it, a lot or Allot? Al-O-O-T.
哦，那真的很有趣。我知道。然后他们还要求房主在拍摄前一周关掉喷水装置，让草看起来有点干枯和饱经风霜。他们照做了。他们为了我们毁了他们的草坪。谢谢。现在，对于吉姆父母家的内部和车库场景，他们在凡奈斯的阿洛特大道上找到了一处空置的房子。离另一栋房子只有几个街区远。对于这一处，他们进去了。他们铺了长毛地毯。他们加了木镶板。他们换了前门。就像他们买了一扇前门，把它装在两栋房子上，这样它们就能匹配，你知道吗？所以他能够进去并完全设计房子的内部。是A-L-L-O-T-T-T-T吗？你读作“a lot”还是“Allot”？Al-O-O-T。
Alet? Alet. So from everything I said, the thing that we're going to discuss is the street name and how to pronounce it. I want you to know something. Whenever I think about where I'm going to live, I think about the name of the street and having to tell it to like the pizza delivery guy. I live on Alat. Allot. No, not Allot.
Alet？Alet。所以根据我说的所有内容，我们要讨论的是街道名称以及如何发音。我想让你知道一件事。每当我考虑我要住在哪里时，我都会考虑街道的名字，以及不得不告诉送披萨的人。我住在Alat。Allot。不，不是Allot。
No, not Allet. Not allot. A lot. I play it out in my head. You guys don't do that? clearly you'd rather live on Calvert Street. Calvert, yes. Much easier for you to get your pizza on Calvert.
不，不是Allet。不是allot。A lot。我在脑子里演练了一遍。你们不这样做吗？显然你宁愿住在卡尔弗特街。卡尔弗特，是的。你在卡尔弗特街买披萨容易多了。
That's right. I'm not spelling that every single time. This is like how strongly I felt about pockets in women's clothing. This is your soapbox moment, Angela. Yeah, I can't tell you. Like how many times I've had to spell my street name out? It's annoying. I'm not going to say it.
没错。我可不想每次都拼写那个名字。这就像我对女性服装口袋的强烈感受一样。这是你的个人演讲时刻，安吉拉。是的，我无法告诉你。我不得不拼写我的街道名字多少次？这很烦人。我不会说的。
don't need the creepers. You don't want anyone in your bush. I don't want anyone. Well, I might want someone in my bush, but I think he already lives with you. I think he. Oh, geez, Louise. Oh, my gosh. I don't know what's happening going to say.
不需要那些偷窥者。你不想让任何人进你的灌木丛。我不想让任何人。嗯，我可能想让某人进我的灌木丛，但我认为他已经和你住在一起了。我想他。哦，天哪。天哪。我不知道发生了什么，我要说什么。
I don't know. Should I go to New York more or less? I don't know. I don't know. All right. We had some more questions because Jim, during the stocking head, he's showing us his parents' house. Mm-hmm. And Sam Kay would like to know, please explain the clown picture in Jim's parents' house.
我不知道。我应该多去纽约还是少去？我不知道。我不知道。好吧。我们还有更多问题，因为吉姆在谈话头期间，他正在向我们展示他父母的房子。嗯哼。萨姆·凯想知道，请解释一下吉姆父母家里的那张小丑画。
Please explain. Yeah. In the script, it just says, Jim examines a hideous painting of some clowns putting out a fire. He tries to pull it off with all his might, nothing. Jim grimaces. Randy Cordray told me that that clown painting was provided it was made originally. for us by one of Phil Shea's go-to artists. He did not have the artist's name in his files. So we'd like to put it out there. If you are listening and you are the person who painted the clown painting, will you contact us on Office Ladies' Pod? We want to know more.
请解释一下。是的。在剧本里，它只是说，吉姆检查了一幅丑陋的画，画的是一些小丑在灭火。他拼命想把它扯下来，但没用。吉姆做了个鬼脸。兰迪·科德雷告诉我，那幅小丑画最初是由菲尔·谢伊的一位御用艺术家为我们制作的。他的档案里没有那位艺术家的名字。所以我们想把它发出来。如果你正在听，而且你就是画那幅小丑画的人，请在Office Ladies的播客上联系我们。我们想了解更多。
But Randy Cordray said that the artist actually provided them with multiple preliminary choices and that Mindy, Greg, Paul, and Jen all had to stand and look at multiple clown paintings, and that's the one they chose. That was their job that day. Yeah. Pick the clown painting. That was your day. I had to pick a clown painting. So crazy. It cracked me up that it was on the wall like that and that he couldn't remove it because I feel like that's such a dad move. You know, it's like that moment where your mom is like, that painting is always tilted. It's always tilted. And then your dad goes and super glues it to
但兰迪·科德雷说，艺术家实际上提供了多个初步选择，明迪、格雷格、保罗和詹都必须站着看多幅小丑画，这就是他们选择的那一幅。那是他们那天的工作。是的。选那幅小丑画。那是你的一天。我不得不选一幅小丑画。太疯狂了。它那样挂在墙上，而且他无法把它取下来，这让我觉得这太像爸爸会做的事了。你知道，就像你妈妈说的那样，那幅画总是歪的。它总是歪的。然后你爸爸就用强力胶把它粘在
the wall because he's tired of it tilting. It just made me laugh. I wanted to know the story behind why they bolted it down. Yeah, what is the story there? There's a story. We don't know what it is exactly. We don't know. Well, now, guess what? Oscar and Andy discover a note on the microwave. It's a very shaming note. It is. They think that the note is worse than the mess. Angela likes the note. She does. Meredith thinks that the person who wrote the note is definitely rich and should get off their high horse. I love this moment with this note on the microwave.
墙上，因为他厌倦了它总是歪着。这让我笑了。我想知道他们为什么把它钉死在那里的故事。是的，那背后的故事是什么？有一个故事。我们不知道具体是什么。我们不知道。好吧，现在，你猜怎么着？奥斯卡和安迪在微波炉上发现了一张纸条。这是一张非常羞辱人的纸条。确实。他们认为这张纸条比脏乱本身更糟糕。安吉拉喜欢这张纸条。她确实喜欢。梅雷迪思认为写这张纸条的人肯定很有钱，应该从高高在上的姿态下来。我喜欢微波炉上这张纸条的时刻。
I do too. It's so relatable. If you have ever worked in an office, there is at least once in your time of working in that office a note stuck to something about something that people are like, eh. Yeah. And also the note where the person leaving the note has clearly reached their limit. Yeah, yeah. They can't take it anymore. No, the note is masking a deep, like, river of anger.
我也喜欢。这太有共鸣了。如果你曾经在办公室工作过，在你工作的这段时间里，至少有一次会看到贴在某物上的关于某事的纸条，人们会觉得，呃。是的。而且写纸条的人显然已经到了极限。是的，是的。他们再也受不了了。不，这张纸条掩盖了一股深深的愤怒。
They're just pissed. Well, I think this is such a fun moment because we get to see Pam and Angela in agreement about something. I think Pam starts to doubt her note a little bit when she realizes that Angela is on her side. Do you think? Yeah, I do. Well, the cool thing is that this moment at the microwave would have. continued. In the script, there are two talking heads here, one from Pam and one from Angela. Mm-hmm. And Lady, I thought we could read them. I did too. And they really further the story.
他们只是气疯了。嗯，我认为这是一个非常有趣的时刻，因为我们看到帕姆和安吉拉在某件事上达成了一致。我想当帕姆意识到安吉拉站在她这边时，她开始对自己写的纸条有点怀疑了。你觉得呢？是的，我确实这么认为。嗯，很酷的是，微波炉前的这个时刻本可以继续下去。在剧本里，这里有两个谈话头，一个是帕姆的，一个是安吉拉的。嗯哼。女士，我想我们可以读一下它们。我也这么想。它们确实推动了故事的发展。
It's so fun. Okay, here was Pam's talking head from the script. She's holding up the note. This is the front of the note. And then it says Pam holds up a memo. This is the front of my latest office memorandum. This can only lead anyone to believe that I wrote the note. Which I did. And then immediately it would cut to Angela's talking head. And this was what was in the script. Everyone keeps asking if I wrote the note on the microwave. It was so perfectly worded and a little bit snotty.
太有趣了。好吧，这是剧本里帕姆的谈话头。她举着那张纸条。这是纸条的正面。然后上面写着帕姆举起一份备忘录。这是我最新办公室备忘录的正面。这只能让任何人相信是我写的这张纸条。确实是我写的。然后它会立即切到安吉拉的谈话头。这就是剧本里的内容。每个人都在问我是不是我写了微波炉上的那张纸条。它的措辞太完美了，而且有点傲慢。
I wish I had written it. Now, there were even more candy bag talking heads, which we'd filmed as well. And they ended up in deleted scenes. But these are the two that were in the script. Yes. And you guys, what cracks me up as well, I don't know. if you notice this. Not only are Pam and Angela kind of oddly on the same side of this argument. Did you notice Jenna that they're dressed alike? Yes. I noticed that Pam is doing that thing that
我真希望是我写的。现在，还有更多的糖果袋谈话头，我们也拍了。它们最终出现在了删除场景中。但这是剧本里的两个。是的。而且你们，让我觉得好笑的是，我不知道你们有没有注意到。帕姆和安吉拉不仅在这个争论中奇怪地站在同一边。詹娜，你注意到她们穿得一样吗？是的。我注意到帕姆在做安吉拉总是做的那种事，她在衬衫外面穿了一件奇怪的短袖毛衣。她们都穿着V领短袖毛衣，里面是短袖衬衫。安吉拉的是棕色配棕色，帕姆的是黑色配紫色。但这件短袖毛衣是什么鬼？我不得不相信这是艾丽西亚·雷克拉夫天才的服装选择。我也这么认为。因为那很有趣。我截了图。
Angela always does where she wears like a weird short sleeve sweater over a blouse. They both have V-neck short-sleeve sweaters over short-sleeved blouses. Angela's is like brown on brown and Pam's is black over purple. But what is this short-sleeve sweater? I have to believe that was a genius wardrobe choice by Alicia Raycraft. I think so. Because that is funny. I screen grabbed them.
我要把它们并排放在故事里。嗯，我们收到了麦迪和劳拉的一个粉丝提问。她们问，在这一集中，帕姆和安吉拉都认为微波炉上的纸条是可以接受且正确的。作为詹娜和安吉拉，你们在现实生活中站在哪一边？留纸条还是不留？你先来。你先来。你先来。为什么你让我先来？哦，我会告诉你。我可能是不留纸条的那种。我只会生闷气，永远怨恨你。我可能是不留纸条的。但这是我对这张纸条的反应。当我看到这张纸条时，我想，你知道吗？你需要这个。无论你是谁，在这个世界上。你需要把它发泄出来。所以我没意见。有一次，詹娜，我永远不会忘记。我在上高中，我终于拿到了驾照，我们去了商场。你知道，你要去商场。
I'm going to put them on side-by-side in stories. Well, we got a fan question from Maddie and Laura. They asked, in the episode, both Pam and Angela agree that the note on the microwave was acceptable and correct. where do you guys stand in real life as Jenna and Angela? Note or no note? You go. You go for you go. Why are you making me go first? Oh, I'll tell you what. I'm probably a no note. I'll just sort of like stew and resent you forever. I'm probably a no note. But here is my reaction to the note. When I see the note, I'm like, you know what? You needed that. Whoever you are out in the world. You needed to get it out. So I'm okay with it. One time, Jenna, I'll never forget this. I was in high school and I had finally gotten my driver's license and we went to the mall. You know, you're going to go to the mall.
我想，詹娜，因为我太兴奋了，我带着朋友在车里。我们在商场。我有点分心。也许我停车停得不是最好。好的。在我们去克莱尔精品店和579店，也许还有蜡烛店逛了一天之后，我们回到我的车旁，发现了一张纸条。等等。我很抱歉。
And I think, Jenna, because I was so excited, I had my friends in the car with me. We're at the mall. I was a little distracted. And maybe I didn't do the best parking job. Okay. And after our day of going to Claire's boutique and hitting up 579, maybe the candle store, we go back out to my car and there was a note. Wait. I'm so sorry.
你买蜡烛？作为一个青少年？这对你来说追溯到那么久以前？是的，我喜欢蜡烛。十几岁的安吉拉去了商场，她去了蜡烛店。她喜欢扬基蜡烛，詹娜。好的。我很抱歉。继续。你到了你的车旁。扬基蜡烛。它就在霍尔马克商店旁边。我可以给自己买张卡片，也许是个小玩意，去买支蜡烛。抱歉。你多大？在这个故事里你大概16岁。我这辈子一直像个老奶奶。不管怎样，我和朋友走回我的车旁。这是我第一次开车去商场。
You bought candles? as a teenager? It goes that far back for you? Yeah, I love a candle. And the Teenage Angela went to the mall and she went to the candle store. She loved Yankee candles, Jenna. Okay. I'm so sorry. Go on. You get to your car. Yankee candles. It was right next to the Hallmark store. I could get myself a card, maybe a knick-knack, go get a candle. I'm sorry. How old are you? You're like, you're 16 in this story. I've been a grandma my whole life. Anyway, I walk back out to my car with my friends. This is my first outing in my car to the mall.
是的。我的挡风玻璃雨刷下有一张纸条。上面写着什么？它是这样写的。嘿，混蛋。下次，给我留个开罐器，这样我就能进我的车了。我当时想，什么？我一定把那个人的车夹在中间了。
Yeah. There's a note under my windshield wiper. What's it say? This is what it said. Hey, dickhead. Next time, leave me a can opener so I can get into my car. I was like, what? I must have sandwiched the guy's car.
我不知道。哦。但你知道吗？我想，他需要这个。无论他是谁，他们需要这个。他们需要把它发泄出来。好的。所以基本上你对纸条的立场是，你自己不会写，但你没有
I don't know. Oh. But you know what? I was like, he needed that. whoever he or she was, they needed this. They needed to get it out. Okay. So basically where you stand on notes is you wouldn't write one yourself, but you don't have
很大的反应。当它们出现时，你不会往心里去。你有点觉得那个人需要把它发泄出来。想想坐下来写一张纸条，或者把它打出来，打印在一张彩色纸上所花的时间，就像帕姆做的那样。她有两种不同的颜色。她有黑色墨水。她有红色墨水。
a big kind of reaction. You don't take them personally when they're out. You sort of like that person needed to get it out. Think about the time it takes to sit down and write a note or type it out and print it on a piece of colored paper like Pam did. She had two different colors. She had black ink. She had red ink.
它是在一张黄色的纸上。她显然需要在这个时刻被听到。是的。所以我只会听她的。如果微波炉脏了，你会清理它吗？我可能会。哇。我可能会直接清理它。
It was on a yellow piece of paper. She clearly needed to be heard in this moment. Yeah. So I would just hear her. Would you clean the microwave if it was dirty? I probably would. Wow. I would probably just clean it.
我的意思是，谁需要？然后就完成了。哇。我只会清理它。如果我走进Earwolf这里的小厨房，水槽周围有一团糟，而且不是我弄的，我只会把它擦干净。这是我会做的。好的。
I mean, who needs? And then it's done. Wow. I would just clean it. If I go into the little kitchen here at Earwolf and there's like a mess around the sink and it's not my mess, I just wipe it up. here's what I would do. Okay.
你看上去很严肃。这就是为什么我想，好吧。嗯，我在脑子里思考。我真的在尝试，你知道，问自己，我是谁？我会做什么？我是个解决问题的人，对吧？所以如果我一直走进厨房，微波炉一直很脏，而且没有关于谁来清理它的制度，我会想要建立那个制度或制定那个规则。
You look very serious. That's why I'm like, okay. Well, I'm thinking about it in my head. I'm really trying to, you know, ask myself, who am I? What would I do? I'm a problem solver, right? So if I kept going in the kitchen and there kept being a dirty microwave and there was no system in place for who cleans it, I would want to create that system or create that rule.
百分之百，詹娜，你会做一个家务轮盘。是的。我们都会，比如在周一，我负责清理办公室水槽。是的。或者这是周一微波炉日。我们会给它起个有趣的名字。那是清理日，它会轮流进行。而且，你知道，其中的一部分是，你保持微波炉越干净，你清理的那天工作量就越少。所以这会激励我们所有人保持微波炉更干净，因为没人想在他们的清理日清理它。我非常喜欢你这一点。你是基于解决方案的。我是。嗯，在剧本里，微波炉的故事线还在继续。现在帕姆原来的纸条上面又多了一张纸条，上面写着，嘿，留下纸条的匿名懦夫，像个男人一样，少花点时间写纸条，多花点时间清理微波炉。是的。然后它继续。在这一集中，微波炉上会有更多的纸条堆积起来。
A hundred percent, Jenna, you would make a chore wheel. Yes. And we would all, like on Mondays, I would be in charge of cleaning the office sink. Yes. Or it's Monday Microwave Day. We'd give it a fun name. And that's the cleaning day and it would rotate around. And, you know, part of that would be the cleaner you keep the microwave, the less work on the day you have to clean it. So it'll incentivize us all to keep a cleaner microwave because no one's going to want to clean it on their clean. clean day. I like that very much about you. You're solution-based. I am. Well, in the script, the microwave storyline continues. There is now another note on top of Pam's original note, and it says this, hey, anonymous coward who left the note, be a man, spend less time writing notes and more time cleaning up the microwave. Yeah. And then it continues. Throughout the episode, there would have been more notes piling up on the microwave.
不仅仅是在微波炉上。它们在橱柜上。微波炉上没地方了。他们把它们贴在微波炉周围的橱柜上。有太多的纸条，显然人们写了多张纸条，因为办公室里甚至没有那么多人来参与这件事，对吧？对。所以这是其中一张纸条。
Not just on the microwave. They're on the cabinets. They ran out of space on the microwave. They're taping them to the cabinets around the microwave. There are so many notes that clearly people have written multiple notes, because there's not even that many people in the office to weigh in on this, right? Right. So here's one of the notes.
嘿，不管是谁在抨击第一张纸条，成熟点。微波炉很脏，这里没人是女佣。然后还有另一张写着，你们都是一群白痴和特权混蛋，没教养。如果我找到你，我会打掉你的牙齿。那一定是梅雷迪思，对吧？你觉得是克里德吗？我觉得是梅雷迪思。
Hey, whoever was bashing the first note, grow up. The microwave is filthy and no one here is a maid. And then there's another one that says, you are all a bunch of idiots and privileged asswipes who weren't raised right. If I find you, I'm going to knock your teeth out. That's got to be Meredith, right? Do you think it's Creed? I think it's Meredith.
我的意思是，梅雷迪思是显而易见的选择，但我认为我们可能会发现是克里德写的。女士，我认为我们应该休息一下，因为当我们回来时，迈克尔即将展现出高水准的表演。我的意思是，小心库尔特·拉塞尔。是的，迈克尔·斯科特要来找你了。他确实是。好吧，我们马上回来。是时候让迈克尔展现他最好的表现了。这是迈克尔最好的表现。
I mean, Meredith is the obvious choice, but I think we could find out that Creed wrote it. Lady, I think we should take a break because when we come back, Michael is about to serve up some high caliber acting. I mean, watch out Kurt Russell. Yeah, Michael Scott's coming for you. He sure is. All right, we'll be right back. It's time for Michael to do his best. This is Michael's best.
嗯哼。迈克尔走向托比的办公桌欢迎他回来。他问关于哥斯达黎加的问题。托比说这很棒，但他回来是因为很难结识人。天气很热。但迈克尔受不了了。他无法忍受这种与托比之间极其天真的闲聊。不，他受不了。他回到办公室。他有这个谈话头，他说，
Mm-hmm. Michael approaches Toby's desk to welcome him back. He's asking questions about Costa Rica. Toby says it was amazing, but he came back because it was kind of hard to meet people. It was hot. But Michael can't stand it. He cannot stand this incredibly innocent small. talk with Toby. No, he can't. He goes back to his office. He has this talking head where he's like,
我试过了，我试过了。我试着和托比谈话并成为他的朋友，但这就像试图和一只邪恶的蜗牛做朋友。我想知道编剧室里是谁想出了“邪恶的蜗牛”，因为它太搞笑了。这是对托比很好的描述。很好的描述。然后他继续说他感觉自己像《惊声尖叫2》里的内芙·坎贝尔，他有一个非常有趣的谈话头，我想他是从那些恐怖电影里学到了很多。但詹娜，剧本里还有另一个谈话头。所以你看到的那个内芙·坎贝尔的，那不在剧本里。所以那一定是他们当天给他的备用谈话头。
I tried, I tried. I tried to talk to Toby and be his friend, but it's like trying to be friends with an evil snail. I want to know who in the writer's room came up with evil snail because it's so funny. It's such a good description of Toby. Such a good description. And then he goes on to say he feels like Neff Campbell and Scream 2 and he has his very funny talking head where he learned a lot, I guess, from the screen movies. But Jenna, there was another talking head in the script. So the one you see with the Nev Campbell, that was not in the script. So that must have been an alternate talking head they handed him on the day.
好的。在剧本里，这是迈克尔的谈话头。几乎是一样的，直到“邪恶的蜗牛”。所以“邪恶的蜗牛”在剧本里。是的，“邪恶的蜗牛”被保留了。我们一直都有那个。但这就是它在剧本里的变化。没有托比的最后四个月
Okay. In the script, this is Michael's talking head. It's almost the same right up until the evil snail. So evil snail was in the script. Yes, evil snail was a keeper. We've always had that. But this is how it changed in the script. The last four months without Toby have.
绝对是极乐。我爱上了一个美丽的金发女人。我失恋了。我尝了扇贝。办公室被闯入了。我当了父亲。我留了山羊胡。奥运会对中国来说是一个巨大的成功。现在我尝到了自由的滋味，我再也回不去了。我要杀了他。不，太过分了。但我会做点什么。不，太少了。我会摆脱他。哦，我喜欢它。我喜欢他对自己所发生的一切的分解。我喜欢他提到他留了山羊胡。我也是。事实上，迈克尔确实要试图摆脱托比。他正在寻找可解雇的罪名。德怀特说他在这个活页夹里能找到两个，职场暴力或性骚扰。所以我猜迈克尔的第一个计划是试图让托比性骚扰帕姆。他走到帕姆的办公桌前。他递给帕姆一张纸条，他说，去把这张纸条给托比。
been absolute bliss. I fell in love with a beautiful blonde woman. I fell out of love. I tried scallops. The office was broken into. I became a father. I grew a goatee. The Olympics were a great success for China. And now that I've tasted freedom, I can never go back. I'm going to kill him. No, too far. But I will do something. No, too little. I will get rid of him. Oh, I like it. I love his breakdown of what all happened. And I love that he included he grew a goatee. me too. It's true, in fact, that Michael is going to try to get rid of Toby. He is looking for fireable offenses. Dwight says there are two that he can find in this binder, workplace violence or sexual harassment. So I guess Michael's first plan is to try to get Toby to sexually harass Pam. He goes up to Pam's desk. He hands Pam a note and he says, go give this note to Toby.
别读它。别读它。帕姆读了它。纸条上写得好像是帕姆写的，上面写着，请拥抱并亲吻我，无论我怎么挣扎。我太害羞了，不敢向你表白我的爱。你能想象如果托比读了那张纸条吗？他的大脑会爆炸的。嗯哼。是的。好吧，那没用。是的。帕姆说，不，我不会去那里的。所以现在新的计划是让托比揍迈克尔。是的。所以他们走回附楼，迈克尔在某种程度上与托比对峙，试图，你知道，激怒他来打他。德怀特说，打他。
Don't read it. Don't read it. Pam reads it. In the note, it's written as if it's from Pam and it says, please hug and kiss me no matter how much I struggle. I'm too shy to confess my love to you. Can you imagine if Toby had read that note? His brain would have exploded. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Well, that doesn't work. Yeah. Pam's like, no, I'm not going back there. So now the new plan is to get Toby to beat up Michael. Yeah. So they marched back to the annex and Michael's sort of confronting Toby and trying to sort of, you know, antagonize him to hit him. And Dwight's like, hit him.
然后凯利很快就跳进来了。打他。我知道。首先，她和瑞恩在亲热。哦，是的。他们停止了亲热，以便他们可以发表意见。他们支持打架。他们说，做吧。
And then Kelly jumps in so quickly. Hit him. I know. First of all, her and Ryan were making out. Oh, yeah. That they've stopped making out so that they can weigh in. And they're for a fight. They're like, do it.
打他。打他。托比拒绝了。没用。这些计划都没用。所以你知道他们必须做什么。他们必须搞大的。他们必须像《盾牌》里那样陷害托比吸毒。我喜欢德怀特说我陷害过很多动物。我陷害过一只浣熊打开圣诞礼物。哦，德怀特。嗯，迈克尔认为这听起来很卑鄙，但有时目的证明手段的卑鄙。那真是一句好台词。真是一句好台词。它太聪明了。它聪明、有趣。它让我想起了这颗宝石。我不迷信，但我有点迷信。是的。它和那个完全一致。所以，是的，迈克尔要去利奥和吉诺那里，在先进冷藏公司买些毒品。他们给了他他们说是两磅大麻的东西，他们想要500美元。迈克尔钱包里有500美元？我也这么想。你钱包里有那么多现金。对于我的背景，捕捉细节的人，你看到那个拉卡瓦纳图书馆卡了吗？
Hit him. Hit him. Toby refuses. It's not working. None of these plans are working. So you know what they're going to have to do. They're going to have to go big. They're going to have to frame Toby for drugs, like on the shield. I love that Dwight said I framed many animals. I framed a raccoon opening a Christmas gift. Oh, Dwight. Well, Michael thinks it sounds mean, but sometimes the end justifies the mean. That's such a good line. Such a good line. It's so smart. It's smart, funny. It reminds me of this gem. I'm not superstitious, but I'm a little bit stitious. Yes. It's right in line with that. So, yeah, Michael's going to go and hit up Leo and Gino over in advance refrigeration for some drugs. They give him what they say is two pounds of weed and they want $500. Michael has $500 in his wallet? I thought the same thing. That's a lot of cash in your wallet. And for my background, catch people, did you see the Lackawanna Library card?
在迈克尔的钱包里？是的，当他打开钱包时，有一张拉卡瓦纳县图书馆卡。你知道我最近清理衣柜时发现了什么吗？什么？帕姆的钱包。你发现了。里面有一张信用卡，上面写着帕姆·比斯利。他们为我的钱包，我的道具钱包做了所有这些卡。
In Michael's wallet? Yes, when he opens his wallet, there's a Lackawanna County Library card. Do you know what I found recently when I was cleaning out my closet? What? Pam's wallet. You did. And in it, there's a credit card that says Pam Beasley. There's all these cards they made for my wallet, my prop wallet.
我会拍张照片。我们会把它放在播客里。是的，我们必须把它放在故事里。太有趣了。那有多疯狂？他们确实做了。这就是菲尔·谢伊的细节程度。是的。如果你有一个道具钱包，它反映了你的角色。虽然，迈克尔要去图书馆吗？那是为了什么？我的意思是，我觉得迈克尔可能在钱包里放那张图书馆卡有20年了。是的。也许有一段时间他没有互联网，他不得不去图书馆。
I'll take a picture. We'll put it in pod. Yeah, we have to put it in stories. That's so fun. How crazy is that? They did that. That's how detailed Phil Shea was. Yep. If you had a prop wallet, it reflected your character. Although, is Michael going to the library and why? What's that for? I mean, I feel like Michael's probably had that library card for like 20 years in his wallet. Yeah. Maybe there was a time where he didn't have internet and he'd have to go to the library.
哦，等等，我们没有互联网。我知道。也许他过去常去图书馆复印，因为办公室里的复印机是垃圾。我们下周会讲到那个。是的。所以，你知道有时候当我们看一集节目或者我们在分解我们的文档来准备做播客时，我们会对某事感到好奇，我们会进行深入研究？你对某事做过吗？我没有。
Oh, wait, we didn't have internet. I know. Maybe he used to go to the library to make copies because the copier in the office is crap. We'll get to that next week. Yeah. So, And you know how when sometimes we're watching an episode or we're breaking down our document to prep to do the podcast, we'll get curious about something and we'll do a deep dive? Did you do one on something? I didn't.
我们的助理制片人安斯利。安斯利，你深入研究了什么？这是她写给我的。她说，根据一次令人遗憾的谷歌搜索，宾夕法尼亚州一磅娱乐用大麻的价格在1500美元到2550美元之间。她必须知道。她当时想，好吧，他们以500美元的价格卖给迈克尔两磅大麻。安斯利感到好奇，宾夕法尼亚州一磅大麻多少钱？现在我看了看，我们是在2008年9月拍摄的。
Our associate producer Ainsley. Ainsley, what did you deep dive? This is what she wrote me. She said, according to a regrettable Google search, the price of one pound of recreational marijuana in Pennsylvania ranges from $1,500 to $2,550. She had to know. She was like, okay, they're selling Michael two pounds of weed for $500. Inslee got curious, how much is a pound of weed in Pennsylvania? And now I looked and we shot this in September of 2008.
所以2008年是多少钱？我不确定，但今天那会花你不少钱。以今天的价格，迈克尔做了一笔交易，因为今天买两磅大麻要花他近5000美元。我还想说，那个袋子里显然不是两磅任何东西。不。它是绿色的，但它不是两磅。我的意思是，两磅，我家里到处都是两磅的东西，比如两磅的重量，两磅的烧瓶袋。那不是两磅任何东西。
So how much was it in 2008? I'm not sure, but today that's going to run you quite a bit of money. With today's prices, Michael got a deal because it would cost him close to $5,000 to get two pounds of weed today. I also want to say that's clearly not two pounds of anything in that baggie. No. It's green, but it's not two pounds. I mean, two pounds, I have two pounds of things all over my house, like two pound weights, two pound bag of flask. That's not two pounds of anything.
它不是。我以前家里有过两磅的菠菜袋。它比那个大得多。它占满了整个保鲜抽屉。你对描绘两磅是什么样子非常热情。我的意思是，那不是两磅，这太明显了。迈克尔错过了这么多迹象。别让詹娜开始。
It's not. I've had a two-pound bag of spinach in my house before. It's much bigger than that. It takes up the whole CRISPR drawer. You're very passionate about painting a very clear picture of what two pounds is. I mean, it's so glaringly obvious that that's not two pounds. There are so many signs that Michael is missing. Don't get Jenna started.
别让我开始两磅某物是什么。我会告诉你关于我的两磅菠菜的事。我刚订了两磅泻盐，那也是一个大包装。你在做什么？温暖、舒缓的沐浴。嗯，听着，我们马上就会发现帕姆在整个微波炉事件中有一个盟友。她有吗？她有瑞恩，他假装是盟友，他表现得很明显，我喜欢它。
Don't get me started on what two pounds of something is. I'll tell you about my two pounds of spinach. I just ordered two pounds of Epsom salts, and that was a large package as well. What are you making? Warm, soothing bath. Well, listen, we're about to find out that Pam has an ally in this whole microwave business. Does she? She has Ryan, who's pretending to be an ally, and he's laying it on thick, and I love it.
是的，他说，我完全站在你这边。但事实是，他去泡了一杯面，微波炉还是一团糟。他想让她清理干净。她发表了一些真正的帕姆式的讽刺。嘿，帕姆，我只是想让你知道。关于微波炉的情况，我完全站在你这边。谢谢。我刚才去后面泡了一杯汤。
Yeah, he says, I'm totally on your side. But the truth is, he went to make a cup of noodles, and the microwave is still a mess. And he wants her to clean it up. And she delivers some real Pam's ass. Hey, Pam, I just want to let you know. I'm totally on your side with the whole microwave situation. Thank you. I was just back there to make some cup of soup.
那东西还是乱七八糟的。我知道。你能相信吗？是的，太疯狂了。但我猜重点是，在某个时候，无论有没有纸条，总得有人进去把它清理干净。我想这就是为什么我们有临时工，对吧？哦，不。相信我，我只会让它变得更糟。
The thing is still a huge mess. I know. Can you believe it? Yeah, it's crazy. But I guess the thing is at some point, notes or no notes, someone's going to have to just get in there and clean it up. I guess that's why we have a temp, huh? Oh, no. trust me, I would just make it worse.
用纸巾擦一下怎么会变得更糟？我会找到办法的。你以前见过东西干净，对吧？帕姆，我对那种事无能为力。我的意思是，那是一些很好的帕姆式讽刺。那全是剧本写的。我知道听起来像詹娜的讽刺。那是剧本写的。
How would wiping it with a paper towel make it worse? I would find a way. You've seen things clean before, though, right? Pam, I'm hopeless to that stuff. I mean, that's some good Pam sass. That was all scripted. I know it sounds like Jenna Sass. It was scripted.
我只是把它带进去了。你带来了一些真正的真相。我确实带进去了。嗯，安吉，我们收到了很多粉丝提问，问到底是谁清理了微波炉？因为这从来没有解决。我们从来没发现。它清理干净了吗？谁清理的？
I just brought myself to it. You brought some real truth to it. I did. Well, Ange, we got a lot of fan questions asking who did clean the microwave? because this never gets wrapped up. We never find out. Did it get clean? Who cleaned it?
这本来会解决的。它在剧本里。我们拍了一个大场景，本来可以解释这一切。那也是一个有趣的场景。确实是。而且它在开头有一个很棒的帕姆和安吉拉的时刻。是的。
This would have wrapped up. It's in the script. And we filmed a big scene that would have explained all of it. It was a fun scene too. It was. And it has a great Pam Angela moment at the top. Yeah.
所以它以安吉拉开始。她从厨房冲进来。她超级生气。她举着一张纸条。有人在纸条上画了一个阴茎。她和帕姆对质。我知道。她认为帕姆画了那个阴茎。为什么她总是因为这种事责怪帕姆？我不知道。事情是这样的。变态。
So it starts with Angela. She's storming in from the kitchen. She's super ticked off. And she's holding up a note. Someone has drawn a penis on the note. And she confronts Pam. I know. She thinks Pam drew the penis. Why did she always blame Pam for this kind of stuff? I don't know. Here's how it went. Pervert.
安吉拉，我没做那种事。所以这就是他们在你那所高级艺术学校教你的吗？我为什么要在我自己的纸条上画一个阴茎？你为什么要穿鲜艳的颜色来博取关注，帕姆？大家，我有一个公告要宣布。我就是那个在微波炉上贴第一张纸条的人。是的，帕姆坦白了。我记得拍摄这个场景，因为帕姆接着开始掌控局面。在她承认她写了那张纸条后，她说，我想我不得不说，这张纸条有什么错？
Angela, I didn't do that. So is this what they taught you at your fancy art school? Why would I draw a penis on my own note? Why do you wear bright colors for attention, Pam? Everyone, I have an announcement to make. I'm the person who put the first note on the microwave. Yeah, Pam comes clean. And I remember shooting this because Pam kind of goes on to take charge of the room. After she admits that she wrote the note, she's like, and I guess I just have to say, what's so wrong about the note?
为什么每个人都被这张纸条冒犯了？难道你不应该对一个一直很脏的微波炉更感到冒犯吗？她登上了她的肥皂箱。这是帕姆的肥皂箱。这是帕姆的肥皂箱。你们，作为一个演员，当我们有机会在 bullpen 面前指挥全局时。这很令人兴奋，同时也让我们感到有点害怕。哦，是的。因为你要负责场景的节奏。这只发生在我身上
Why is everyone so offended by this note? Shouldn't you be more offended by a consistently dirty microwave? She gets on her soapbox. It's Pam's soapbox. It's Pam's soapbox. And you guys, as an actor, when we got to have. have a moment where we commanded the whole bullpen. It was exciting and also we were like kind of terrified. Oh, yeah. Because you're in charge of like the pace of the scene. This only happened to me
几次，当安吉拉宣布重大消息或类似的事情时。但我记得詹娜看着你，你在这一刻表现得太好了，因为每个人都在给你扔小球。你知道，奥斯卡、斯坦利和凯文，你知道，他们都在讽刺你。而且你知道，我上次有这样的场景是在《海滩游戏》里，当时帕姆要向整个团队面对她的感受，以及他们为什么没来参加她的艺术展。但在这种情况下，人们在打断我，他们冲着我来。我得到了一个窗口，看到了史蒂夫每天的生活是什么样的。是的。在某个时刻，团队开始欺负帕姆关于去纽约的事。帕姆发表了这段演讲，让吉姆措手不及。我想我们应该听听。
a handful of times when Angela makes a big announcement or something. But I remember Jenna watching you and you were so good in this moment because everyone is like throwing you little curve balls. You know, Oscar and Stanley and Kevin, you know, they're all kind of sassing you. And you know, the last time that I had a scene like this was back in beach games when Pam is going to. to confront the whole group about her feelings and how they didn't come to her art show. But in this instance, people were interrupting me and they're coming at me. And I got such a window into what Steve's every day was. Yeah. At one point, the group starts hazing Pam about being in New York. And Pam gives this speech that kind of takes Jim off guard. And I think we should hear it.
听着，纽约。那可能行得通。为什么？因为我去了纽约三个月。三个月？那个和黑色毛衣，曼哈顿。好的，是的。我去了纽约，各位。我不会为此道歉。我在那里一周经历的事情比我在这里三个月经历的还要多。我爱纽约。你知道，我特别喜欢那里的人清理他们自己的东西。嗯，吉姆刚刚听到她说了所有这些。是的，摄像机正在推向他的脸，他意识到在今天结束时，他要告诉她他为他们在斯克兰顿买了一栋房子。她短期内不会回纽约了。这个她爱的地方。我真的希望这一刻能进入节目，因为我觉得它为吉姆设定了赌注，因为他从一开始就怀疑他的决定。我做对了吗？她会喜欢这个吗？我不知道。我觉得他需要听到这个。我觉得观众也需要听到它。我也这么认为。我觉得它被剪掉真是太可惜了。而且你知道，在整个场景结束时，帕姆说，好吧，我去清理它。所以最终是帕姆清理了微波炉。是的，在剧本里，这个大场景的最后一行写着这个。帕姆大步走向厨房，斯坦利开始缓慢鼓掌。哦，是的。我们有一个缓慢鼓掌的场景，但没用上。
Listen, New York. That might fly. Why? Because I went to New York for three. Three months? That and the black sweater, Manhattan. Okay, yes. I went to New York, everybody. I'm not going to apologize for it. I experienced more there in one week than I experienced here in three months. I love New York. You know, I especially love that people there cleaned up after themselves. Well, Jim has just heard her say all that. Yeah, and the camera is pushing in on his face, and he's realizing at the end of today, he's going to tell her he bought them a house in Scranton. She's not going back to New York anytime soon. This place she loves. I really wish this moment had made it into the show because I feel like it just sets up the stakes for Jim because he's doubting his decision from the very beginning. Did I do the right thing? Is she going to like this? I don't know. And I feel like he needed to hear this. And I feel like the audience needed to hear it. I do too. I think it's a shame that it got cut out. And you know, at the end of this whole scene, Pam says, fine, I'll go clean it. So it is Pam in the end who cleaned the microwave. Yes, in the script, the very last line of this big scene says this. Pam marches over to the kitchen and Stanley starts to slow clap. Oh, yeah. We had a slow clap that didn't make it.
哦，是的，没错。哦，那勾起了我走向斯坦利缓慢鼓掌的回忆。嗯哼。太好了。太好了。是时候让迈克尔把他认为是两磅大麻的东西种在托比的办公桌里了。与此同时，德怀特要打电话给警察，报告说有一个名叫托比·弗兰德森的毒贩在现场。当被要求提供他的名字时，德怀特说他的名字是安迪·伯纳德。德怀特会抓住任何机会把安迪推向火坑。詹娜，有一个删除的场景，为了让迈克尔有时间去种毒品，他们需要把托比从他的办公桌前引开。
Oh, yeah, that's right. Oh, that's bringing back that memory of me walking to Stanley's slow clap. Mm-hmm. So good. So good. It's time for Michael. to plant what he thinks is two pounds of marijuana in Toby's desk. And at the same time, Dwight is going to call the police and report that there is a drug dealer named Toby Flanderson on the premises. And when asked to give his name, Dwight says his name is Andy Bernard. Dwight is going to throw Andy under the bus any chance he gets. There was this deleted scene, Jenna, that for Michael to be able to have the time to go plant the drugs, they needed to get Toby away from his desk.
所以德怀特让托比给他看他在哥斯达黎加的照片。我们去会议室吧。我会看你的照片。托比很高兴有人想看他的照片。然后迈克尔溜走去种毒品。但以迈克尔的风格，他守不住秘密。他必须和某人分享他可能刚刚做了一些事。这是他说的。
So Dwight asked Toby to show him his photos from Costa Rica. Let's go to the conference room. I'll look at your photos. Toby is thrilled that someone wants to see his photos. And then Michael sneaks off to plant the drugs. But in true Michael fashion, he can't keep the secret. He has to share with someone that he might have just done something. This is what he said.
我觉得你想看我的照片真的很酷。那个白色椭圆形上的粉色东西是什么？那是我。我在趴板冲浪。我不能尝试。谁拍的这张照片？你交到朋友了吗？我雇了一个当地的孩子拍的。告诉我关于这只猴子的事。
I think it's really cool that you wanted to see my photos. What's this for a pink thing on that white oval? That's me. I was boogie boarding. I can't try. Who took this picture? Did you make some friends? I hired a local kid to snap it. Tell me about this monkey.
好的，我不能……我不方便谈论它。我们只能说我某人某事了某人某事。如果被发现，那么某人会得到某事。我可能说过，你呢？我可能说得太多了。他不能什么都不说。他不能。
Okay, I'm not... I am not at liberty to talk about it. Let's just say that I somethinged something in somebody something. And if discovered, then someone will get something. I may have said, do you? I may have said too much. He can't not say anything. He can't.
克制不是他的强项。不。然后我必须说，那个德怀特和托比的场景，对我来说，听起来像雷恩·威尔逊在即兴提问，试图难倒保罗·利伯斯坦。詹娜，你没说错。我正在看剧本。关于那个在椭圆形上爬行的红色东西是什么的部分，那是剧本写的。好的。但“告诉我关于这只猴子的事”不在剧本里。
Containment is not his strong suit. No. And then I have to say that scene with Dwight and Toby, to me, it sounded like Rain Wilson improvising questions trying to stump Paul Lieberstein. Jenna, you're not wrong. I'm looking at the script right now. The part with what's the red thing crawling on that oval, that was scripted. Okay. But the tell me about this monkey is not in the script.
好的。还有，那个问题呢？谁拍的这些照片？那在剧本里。哦，是吗？是的。那是一句有趣的台词。即兴时刻是猴子。好的。
Okay. Also, what about that question? Who took these pictures? That's in the script. Oh, it is? Yeah. That's a funny line. The improv moment is the monkey. Okay.
现在警察到了，他们要调查这个可能的毒品情况。帕姆对此一无所知。德怀特要负责。然后迈克尔开始惊慌失措。是的。然后他们意识到那是一袋Ziploc，也许是什么，卡普里沙拉？是的。看起来里面肯定有一些奶酪。
Now the police arrive and they are going to look into this possible narcotics situation. Pam doesn't know anything about it. Dwight's going to take charge. And then Michael starts freaking out. Yes. And then they realize it's a Ziploc of maybe like what, a caprici salad? Yeah. It looks like there's definitely some cheese in there.
嗯哼。还有一些沙拉酱。是的。我得让你知道，警察是由帕特里克·福塞特和迈克尔·赫罗迪扮演的，他们两个都没有上过《神探阿蒙》，我查过了。哦，查得好。另外，我们能谈谈当警察第一次到达时，克里德站起来好像要被戴上手铐吗？然后把手放在脑后。
Mm-hmm. And some salad dressing. Yeah. I'll have you know the police officers were played by Patrick Fawcett and Michael Herody, and neither of them have been on Monk, I checked. Oh, good call to check, though. Also, can we talk about how when the police first arrived, Creed stood up as if he was going to be handcuffed? And then put his hands behind his head.
是的。然后他的谈话头，他说，一直跟我说话直到警察离开。我喜欢它。太好了。我太喜欢它了。我们收到了一些粉丝来信。布鲁克·L说托比似乎非常担心警察搜查他的办公桌。这可能是因为他们可能会发现他是斯克兰顿勒杀手的证据吗？
Yeah. And then his talking head where he's like, just keep talking to me until the police leave. I love it. So good. I love it so much. We got some fan mail. Brooke L. said that Toby seemed very concerned about police officers searching his desk. Could this be because they might find evidence of him being the Scrant and Strangler?
哦。我不知道。在16分27秒，我们有一个非常罕见的并排谈话头。太罕见了。他们是怎么熬过来的？我不知道。迈克尔和托比并排。我知道。
Oh. I don't know. At 16 minutes, 27 seconds, we have a very rare side-by-side talking head. So rare. How did they get through it? I don't know. Michael and Toby side-by-side. I know.
我真希望我是那个谈话头里墙上的一只苍蝇，因为你知道。我找了花絮。我想，肯定，肯定花絮里有什么。是的，因为我想，我认识这些人。我认识史蒂夫和保罗在一起。他们和观众一样，和我们所有人一样，被托比和迈克尔的关系逗乐了。是的。他们会互相捉弄。
I would have loved to been a fly on a wall in that talking head because you know. I looked for the bloopers. I was like, surely, surely there's something on the blooper reel. Yes, because I was like, I know these guys. I know Steve and Paul together. And they were as tickled by the Toby Michael relationship as the audience was as we all were. Yes. And they would mess with each other.
你记得在某个场景里有一个花絮，托比不得不递给迈克尔一张纸，史蒂夫和他开始大笑，因为保罗在上面写了“你”？是的。所以我知道他们互相捉弄，我希望这里有一些花絮。肯定有录像在某处。好吧，听着，在附楼里，瑞恩和凯利又在亲热了。哦，那也是一个邋遢的亲热。确实是。
You remember in a scene there's a blooper where Toby has to hand Michael a piece of paper and Steve and him start cracking up because Paul wrote you on it? Yes. So I know they were giving it to each other, and I wish there were some bloopers from this. There is footage somewhere for sure. Well, listen, in the annex, Ryan and Kelly are making out again. Oh, it's such a sloppy makeout, too. It is.
并不是说整洁的亲热会让它在工作中变得更好。正是如此。好吧，瑞恩想退出。他不想邋遢的亲热。他也不想要整洁的。他要去泰国。和一些高中的朋友，一所高中。你知道，他必须和她分手，因为如果他不这样做，他会永远怨恨她。
Not that a tidy makeout would have made it any better at work. Exactly. Well, Ryan wants out. He doesn't want a sloppy makeout. He doesn't want a tidy one. He's going to Thailand. with some friends from high school, a high school. You know, he has to break up with her because if he doesn't, he'll always resent her.
并不是说一次体面的亲热就能让工作中的情况好转。确实。嗯，瑞安想退出。他不想来一次草率的亲热，也不想要一次体面的。他要和几个高中朋友去泰国。你知道，他必须和她分手，因为如果不这样做，他会一直怨恨她。
If he didn't go, he would like them to be adults about it. Maybe they could have sex one more time. And does she have any cash? Then let's be adults about it, but we could also have sex one more time. That's such a dude move. I feel like I've heard that so many times. I know. Do you want to have some goodbye sex?
如果他不走，他希望他们能成熟地面对。也许他们可以再做爱一次。她有现金吗？那我们就成熟点，但我们也可以再做爱一次。这真是男人的做法。我觉得我听过太多次了。我知道。你想来一次告别性爱吗？
No. No, just goodbye. Get your sorry ass out of here. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Fan question from Gracie are, when Ryan is telling Kelly he's going to Thailand, why are they both wearing different clothes? I'll tell you, Gracie, because this scene was originally supposed to be the tag at the end of the episode. And it was meant to be a new work day.
不。不，只是告别。把你那可怜的屁股从这儿挪开。是的，没错。是的。来自Gracie的粉丝提问：当Ryan告诉Kelly他要去泰国时，为什么他们穿的衣服不一样？我告诉你，Gracie，因为这一幕原本应该是这一集结尾的彩蛋。而且那本来是新的一天。
So in the script, this scene was not during the same day that we were framing Toby. It was the next day. But in editing, they moved it up, and we are going to end instead with a delicious Dwight-talking head. We'll get to it. But first, Jim needs to show Pam what he's done. That's right. Jim is nervous but excited. He is, as my daughter says, nervous-sided.
所以在剧本里，这一幕并不是在陷害Toby的那一天发生的。是第二天。但在剪辑时，他们把它提前了，我们最后将以一段精彩的Dwight独白结束。我们稍后会讲到。但首先，Jim需要向Pam展示他做了什么。没错。Jim很紧张但很兴奋。正如我女儿所说，他是“紧张兴奋”的。
And she's like, why are we stopping at your parents' house? And he says, I bought it. And then Jenna, at 18 minutes, two seconds, Jim says, let's go inside. I'll show you inside. What? Has Pam never been inside the house? We got so much mail about that. People wrote in.
她说，为什么我们要停在你父母家？他说，我把它买下来了。然后Jenna，在18分02秒，Jim说，我们进去吧。我带你看看里面。什么？Pam从来没进过这房子吗？我们收到了很多关于这个的邮件。人们写信来问。
They said if Pam knew they were at Jim's parents' house when they pulled up, wouldn't that mean she's been there before and she's probably been inside? You would hope Pam has been inside his parents' house. They've been dating for a while. They live in the same town. Yeah. And it's interesting because his parents have moved out, but they've left some furniture. Also, how rough were they on that?
他们说如果Pam在车停下时就知道他们到了Jim父母家，那不就意味着她以前去过那里，而且可能进去过吗？你当然希望Pam进过他父母的家。他们已经约会一段时间了。他们住在同一个镇上。是的。而且很有趣，因为他父母已经搬走了，但留下了一些家具。还有，他们对那房子有多粗鲁啊？
this house. I know. And Jim says I was helping my mom out. Where's his dad? I don't know. I have a lot of questions. There were a lot of questions. Rachel M. and Megan L. said, question for Jenna. In this episode, when Jim is showing Pam, his parents' house, I was wondering, what went into how you decided to play this scene? Because she seems really worried and unexcited, but then in the end, she says she loves it. Any input you could give about how you decided to play this or what the director told you would be super appreciated. Well, guys, we've already discussed my personal opinions on someone buying someone else a house without telling them. So this was a little bit of a mental gymnastics for me. To get Pam to the place where she's going to say she loves it and where she says that line, I mean, you bought me a house. Because it was like,
这房子。我知道。Jim说我在帮我妈。他爸呢？我不知道。我有很多疑问。有很多问题。Rachel M.和Megan L.说，问Jenna一个问题。在这一集中，当Jim向Pam展示他父母的房子时，我很好奇，你是怎么决定如何演绎这一幕的？因为她看起来很担心，一点也不兴奋，但最后她说她很喜欢。关于你如何决定这样演，或者导演告诉了你什么，如果你能分享一下，我们将不胜感激。好吧，伙计们，我们已经讨论过我个人对于在不告诉对方的情况下买房的看法了。所以这对我来说有点心理体操。要让Pam达到她说她喜欢这个地方，并说出那句台词，我是说，你给我买了一栋房子。因为这就像是，
not how I would react as Jenna. You know, I had to really play the character and play the character's truth. And in the script, I was being told that my character's truth was that she loved this gesture and it made her feel loved. Yeah. Well, I mean, I think we often did that. Obviously, we had to play the truth for the character. I mean, I hope you guys know I'm not very much like Angela Martin and how I would react to things. But it made sense to me, Jenna, for Pam, you know, and Jim made the garage into this art studio. And he's really putting down some roots with her. And I think Pam wanted a family and she wanted all of these things that Jim is offering her. She had wanted that. Yeah, you know, I had thought a little bit back on the talking
这不是我作为Jenna会有的反应。你知道，我必须真正进入角色，演绎角色的真实感受。在剧本里，我被告知我角色的真实感受是她喜欢这个举动，这让她感到被爱。是的。嗯，我的意思是，我想我们经常这样做。显然，我们必须演绎角色的真实感受。我的意思是，我希望你们知道我并不像Angela Martin那样处理事情。但对我来说，Jenna，这对于Pam来说是有意义的，你知道，Jim把车库改成了艺术工作室。他真的在和她扎根。我想Pam想要一个家庭，她想要Jim提供给她的所有这些东西。她一直想要那个。是的，你知道，我回想了一下Pam讨论她理想中的家是什么样子的独白，她一直想要一个带露台的家。你知道，挑选她的家似乎是Pam很在意的事情。所以我确实提到了这一点。我说，你知道，我们已经确定Pam曾幻想过她的家会是什么样子。现在这个人把她排除在过程之外了。你在拍摄时向编剧提过这一点吗？是的。所以我当时在说，帮我理解为什么Pam现在这么开心，这么兴奋。Angela，我们得出了你刚才说的结论，那就是Pam放弃艺术学校的道路是一件很脆弱的事情。她这样做有两个原因。第一，平面设计并不是她作为艺术家真正想做的。第二，她准备好了。她非常、非常准备好开始这种婚姻生活，与这个她等待了多年的男人一起进入家庭和婚姻的阶段。所以这个家是她
head where Pam discusses what her perfect home would look like, how she always wanted a home with a Terrace. You know, picking her home seemed like something that Pam was attached to. So I did bring that up. I said, you know, we've established that Pam has daydreamed about what her home would look like. And now this person has taken her out of the process. You brought that up to the writers at the time of when we were filming? Yeah. And so I was saying, like, help me understand why Pam now is so. happy and so excited. And Angela, we got to exactly what you just said, which was that it was a vulnerable thing for Pam to give up the art school track. And she did that because of two reasons. One, graphic design wasn't what she meant she wanted to do as an artist. And two, she's ready. She's very, very ready to start living this married life, to be in the sea. of family and marriage with this man that she's been waiting years for. And so this home is her
通往她人生那个阶段的快车道。她已经准备好了。是的。而且你知道，他们将一起装修它。所以仍然有那种筑巢的元素会发生。所以这就是我当时的想法，就像是，我准备好了。是的。而且你必须想到，当Pam谈论她梦想中带有塔楼和露台的房子时，她处于一段不幸福的关系中。当你处于生活中感到受困或不快乐的地方时，你会做白日梦。你会幻想那些奇幻的东西，它们是应对机制。然后当你和真正爱的人在一起时，你就不再需要幻想了。
fast track to that season of her life. And she's just ready. Yeah. And you know, they're going to get to fix it up together. So there's still that element of nesting that's going to get to happen. And so that's kind of what I was thinking was like, I'm ready. Yeah. And you have to think, When Pam talked about her dream house with this tower and the terrace and all of that, she was in an unhappy relationship. When you're in a place you feel stuck in life or you're unhappy, you daydream. And you daydream about these fantastical things and they're coping mechanisms. And then when you're with someone you really love, you don't need the fantasy anymore.
那真是个好观点，Angela。你只是准备好过生活了。她准备好过那种生活了。是的。现在，我们确实收到了一些关于那个车库的邮件。Katie C和Chris G说，当Jim向Pam展示他父母的房子时，他说车库采光很好。然后他打开了一个没有窗户的车库门，露出了一个完全没有窗户的车库空间。采光好的地方在哪，Jim？在哪？好吧，我觉得那真的很有趣。那真的很有趣。我想让你们知道，我有一个车库，我们把它用作家庭办公室。很长一段时间，我们只是把门升起来。然后就会有很棒的光线。所以它确实有很好的光线，但你必须把门升起来。后来几年，我们实际上把门拆了，因为我们觉得，这永远不会再是车库了。你知道，我们把它改成了这个小家庭办公室，并装了一个真正的推拉玻璃门。但我明白了。它确实有很好的采光。你只需要
That's such a good point, Angela. You're just ready to have a life. And she's ready to have that life. Yeah. Now, we did get some mail about that garage. Katie C and Chris G. said, when Jim is showing Pam his parents' house, he says the garage has great lighting. He then proceeds to open a windowless garage door revealing a completely windowless garage space. Where's the great lighting, Jim? Where? Okay, well, I thought that was really funny. That is really funny. I want you guys to know that I have a garage that we use as a home office. And for a long time, time, we would just raise the door. And then there would be amazing light. So it did get great light, but you had to raise the door. And then years later, we actually just removed the door because we're like, this is never going to be a garage again. You know, we've sort of made it into this little home office and put an actual sliding glass door. But I get it. It does have great lighting. You just
把它打开。但他表现得好像这个车库采光很好。就好像你打开其他车库，建筑物的整个侧面都不会有很好的采光一样。他表现得好像这是一个特殊功能，适用于每个没有在前面种一棵大树的车库，而它本来就不会有，因为它是个车库。没错。大多数车库只是没有窗户的盒子。我必须告诉你们关于在房子里拍摄这些场景的两件事。Jim试图把小丑画从墙上取下来的那一幕，是我在剧中笑得最厉害的场景之一。这是第二厉害的一次。
have to open it up. But he does present it like this garage has great lighting. As if the other garages that you open, the whole side of the building wouldn't have great lighting. He's presenting as if it's like a special feature that kind of applies to every garage that doesn't have like a giant tree planted in front of it, which it wouldn't because it's a garage. Right. Most garages are just boxes with no windows. I have to tell you two things about shooting these scenes at the house. The scene where Jim is trying to take the clown painting off the wall for paintings. is one of the hardest I've ever laughed on the show. It is the second hardest time.
第一次是我们拍《晚宴》那一集，Michael向我们展示墙上那台小电视的时候。这是第二次。每次John试图把墙上的画取下来，我就忍不住笑。我不知道是怎么回事。眼泪，眼泪，笑得喘不过气来。我们笑得太厉害了。
The first was when we did the scene in dinner party where Michael's showing us the tiny TV on the wall. This is the second. Every time John tried to lift the painting on the wall, I could not stop laughing. I don't know what it was. Tears, tears, choking on our laughter. We laughed so hard.
我在花絮里找过，但没有。我很难过它不在里面。我们花了大约一个小时才拍完他试图把画从墙上取下来的那个小片段。把画从墙上取下来。John在肢体喜剧方面也很有天赋。是的。当他剥开那层假木镶板时，我大声笑了出来，那确实吓了他一跳。
I looked for it in the bloopers, and it's not there. and I'm so upset it's not there. It took us like an hour to shoot that tiny moment of him trying to take the painting off the wall. The painting off the wall. John is also so funny at physical comedy. Yes. I laughed out loud when he peeled back that fake wood paneling and it kind of startled him.
是的。所以在车库那一幕结束时，当我们拥抱时，我即兴发挥了一句台词，“那小丑怎么办？”这让John笑了。这就是为什么他把头埋进我的脖子里。然后当他说，“是的，我对此无能为力。”这让我笑了。所以我把脸埋进他的肩膀里。
Yes. So then at the end of the scene in the garage, when we're hugging, I improvised the line, What about the clown? And it made John laugh. and that's why he's like burying his head into my neck. And then when he said, yeah, I can't do anything about that. It made me laugh. And so I'm like smushing my face into his shoulder.
你完全看得出来我们笑场了。这就是原因，因为我们仍然，每当我们提到小丑画，我们就控制不住。我喜欢那一刻。它让那一幕变得亲密、有趣且甜蜜。我想是时候谈谈史上最伟大的Dwight独白了。这评价很高，因为有很多很棒的Dwight独白，但这一段真的可以排进前五名。
You can totally tell we're breaking. And that's why it was because we were still, anytime we brought up the clown painting, we lost it. I love that moment. It made it intimate and funny and sweet. I think it's time to talk about the greatest Dwight talking head of all time. That's saying a lot because there are some. amazing Dwight talking heads, but this one really is like top five.
他要描述他的完美犯罪，我想我们必须听听。什么是我的完美犯罪？我在午夜闯入Tiffany's。我去拿保险库吗？不，我去拿吊灯。它是无价的。当我把它取下来时，一个女人抓住了我。她让我停下。
He's going to describe his perfect crime, and I think we have to hear it. What is my perfect crime? I break into Tiffany's in midnight. Do I go for the vault? No, I go for the chandelier. It's priceless. As I'm taking it down, a woman catches me. She tells me to stop.
那是她父亲的生意。她是Tiffany。我说，不。我们整晚都在做爱。早上，警察来了，我穿着他们的制服逃跑了。我告诉她去墨西哥见我，但我去了加拿大。我不信任她。再说，我喜欢寒冷。
It's her father's business. She's Tiffany. I say, no. We make love all night. In the morning, the cops come, and I escape in one of their uniforms. I tell her to meet me in Mexico, but I go to Canada. I don't trust her. Besides, I like the cold.
30年后，我收到一张明信片。我有一个儿子，他是警察局长。故事变得有趣的地方就在这里。我告诉Tiffany在巴黎的特罗卡德罗广场见我。她这些年来一直等着我。她从未找过其他情人。我不在乎。我没出现。
30 years later, I get a postcard. I have a son, and he's the chief of police. This is where the story gets interesting. I tell Tiffany to meet me in Paris by the Trocadero. She's been waiting for me all these years. She's never taken another lover. I don't care. I don't show up.
我去了柏林。那就是我藏吊灯的地方。是的。我不知道Rain是怎么忍住说出“故事变得有趣的地方就在这里”这句话的。每次我看这一集，我都会被那句台词逗笑，我看了大概三遍。这段完整的独白是写在剧本里的，而且是照着剧本演的。我认为这是有史以来写得最精彩的片段之一。
I go to Berlin. That's where I stashed the chandelier. Yeah. I do not know how Rain got through saying this is where the story gets interesting. Every time I watch this episode, I laughed at that line, and I watched it like three times. This entire Talking Head was scripted, and it was delivered as scripted. I think this is one of the most brilliantly written pieces ever.
它太棒了。太棒了。还有谁比Rain Wilson饰演的Dwight更适合演绎它呢？简直完美。我同意。好了，各位，这就是《陷害Toby》。你还有什么要说的吗，Angela？
It's just so good. It's so good. And who better to deliver it than Rain Wilson as Dwight? It was just perfect. I agree. There you have it, everyone. That's framed Toby. Did you have anything else, Angela?
我没什么要说的了。我确实想让你们知道，因为Jenna和我看了花絮。下周的《盈余》是我在场景中笑得最厉害的一次。哦，我等不及了。非常感谢Randy Cordray、James Carey、Jen Salad和Paul Lieberstein。我也和他们交换了一些邮件。天哪，那太有趣了。那真是一种享受。我会尝试用你的方法清洁我的微波炉。谢谢。我们下周见。
I don't have anything else. I do want you guys to know because Jen and I both watched the bloopers. Next week on the surplus was one of the hardest I've ever laughed in a scene. Oh, I can't wait. Thank you so much to Randy Cordray, James Carey, and Jen Salad and Paul Lieberstein. I traded some emails with them as well. Man, that was fun. That was a delight. I will be trying to clean my microwave using your method. Thank you. And we'll see you here. next week.
我下周会回到洛杉矶。我在想，我会把纽约的Jenna带回家吗？我们走着瞧。我不知道。纽约的Jenna可能会在我们的播客旁边得到一个E。抱歉。我能说什么呢？下周见，伙计们。
I'll be back in L.A. next week. I wonder, will I bring New York Jenna home with me? We'll see. I don't know. New York Jenna might get the E next to our podcast. Sorry. What can I say? See you next week, guys.
下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由Jenna Fisher和Angela Kins制作。我们的高级制作人是Matt Beagle。我们的第二杯剧集由Molly Nugent制作。我们的音频工程师是Sam Keefer。
See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kins. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our second drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Keefer.
Odyssey的执行制作人是Leah Reese Dennis。《办公室女士》由Bill Shultz混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton的《Rubber Tree》。嘿大家，我是Kelly Clarkson，代表Wayfair。有没有在网上订购过家具并想过“如果……会怎样”？比如，如果它不耐用怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你应该从Wayfair订购。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Hey y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair.
有了Wayfair，就没有“如果会怎样”。只有你喜欢的风格和你可以信赖的质量。访问Wayfair。Wayfair，每种风格，每个家。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
With Wayfair, there's no what if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit Wayfair. Way fair, every style, every home. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。